une production du studio sf mais un mot
sans filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut que nos invités date seach ph
quentin avec moi d'hommes plantes il ya
plusieurs podcast en ce moment qu'on a
tourné que sont disponibles sur pétrole
mais qui sont pas encore sorties
maintenant donc si vous voulez avoir les
podcasts en avant-première allez vous
abonner à notre pétillante ça vous donne
aussi accès ou encore moins de filtres
contenus exclusifs qu'on fait après
chaque pas de casse tout ce qu'on
discute de la conversation qu'ont bien
d'avoir le lien est dans la description
d'hommes pas de gaz d'actualité cette
semaine nos podcasts on voulait parler
de ce sujet le conflit qui très lourd et
ce n'est pas ce que ça se passe en ce
moment puis on voulait le plus
rapidement possible en parler pour
pouvoir comprendre un peu mieux la
nature de ce confit lucky l'origine
aussi de ce conflit
on a reçu sabrina mehr qui est
journaliste et travaille comme
indépendante qui travaille aussi avec
radio canada qui a habité pendant 4 à 1
jérusalem que couvert ce conflit est
qu'il connaît vraiment mieux que
n'importe qui en fait ça a été super
éclairant moi j'ai appris beaucoup c'est
un peu flou au moins c'était quoi ce
conflit le pilat cours toute la
complexité de ce on a vraiment je pense
qu'après une conversation le
ça va être plus clair pour beaucoup de
gens pour nous beaucoup de jack qui vont
écouter ceux de comprendre ce conflit le
vraiment piller way fait qu'en fait si
vous l'écoutez vendredi on le tourne
elle avait donc peut être que de
nouvelles informations peut-être que non
dans tous les cas avant d'y aller en
fait avant la conversion vous remercier
nos sponsors fait que bon votre liste le
podcast de cette semaine et présenté par
communauto sis à ben afar que la
pandémie va nous avoir à crise et qu'on
n'a plus besoin de se déplacer tant que
ce mois chez que je loue une voiture pis
que 95% et parqués dans ma rue puis à
100 à rien mais comme une auto ça vient
régler ce problème là parce que vous
pouvez louer une voiture comme on loue
un hôtel vous pouvez faire ça 30 jours à
l'avant sous dernière minute pour vos
déplacements lorsque vous avez besoin
d'une voiture vous ne payez cas
l'utilisation fait pas d'affaires
d'abonnement ou ultra long terme donc
chaque vous voulez je suis une voiture
vous le payez quelle utilisation
les frais comprennent les assurances les
sens
la réparation fait que c'est la chose la
plus chiante d'une voiture c'est la
réparation ça coûte cher même réparant
chaud puis il y en a partout à montréal
il ya plus de deux mille voitures à
moriat liane dans le parking
il ya un parking communauto en fait dans
le parking du studio fait que c'est
vraiment accessible à tous communauto
cette entreprise qui est 100% le cas
lyon une dimension sociale une dimension
urbanistique une dimension
environnementale urbanistique parce que
ça réduit vraiment beaucoup le trafic
sur les routes
un communauto ça réduit de 10 voitures
de moins sur les routes une voiture
notre partage ça fait une grande
différence
puis le tout partage ça correspond à une
réduction de 1 point de taux de co2 par
personne par amy fac si vous voulez
participer à l'effort collectif de
réduire les rejets es de réduire le
trafic
communauto c'est vraiment une très bonne
option yes fécales et chez qui ça vous
pouvez aller sur leur site web qu'on va
mettre dans la description du podcast
qui merci comme nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que dit à wral merci d'être là merci à
vous de l'invitation serait été rapides
comme si j'étais encore au nom de le
jeter et cris pfff les gamins jeudi
parfait mais c'est là que ça se passe
exact parce qu'un cessez le feu qui est
en train de négocier actuellement en
tout cas en coulisses donc au moment où
on se parle il y en a pas encore mais
peut-être que demain en horreur donc
c'est plus que ce que toujours en
coulisses je m'en voulais c'est que
quand on négocie un cessez le feu entre
israël et le hamas à se passe jamais
publiquement israël veut jamais dire
publiquement je en train de négocier
avec le hamas un groupe qui considèrent
comme terroristes comme les états unis
le canada entre autres
donc ça se passe en coulisses ça se
passe entre le qatar les nations unies
l'egypte aussi qui joue un très grand
rôle dans les négociations
et là aussi que les etats-unis aussi qui
font pression donc quand je dis en
coulisses et que des pourparlers entre
les deux parties sur comment on va
réussir à s'entendre pour arrêter les
hostilités alors là évidemment que le
hamas par exemple demande des choses sur
jérusalem et l'a ensuite israël a aussi
des demandes pour le hamas est ce qu'ils
vont réussir à s'entendre
ça peut être compliqué mais quand il ya
toujours des négociations de cessez le
feu comme ça il ya aussi regagné
d'hostilité c'est ce qu'on a vu au cours
des dernières heures y avait eu une
accalmie la nuit dernière et l'on ne
veut on n'a vu qu'une reprise des
bombardements était rock est aussi fait
que ça se pourrait que l'époque le
conflit j'imagine va pas être résolue et
avec un cessez le feu mais ça pour ça se
pourrait qu éminemment ça se calme ça
pourrait se calmer dans les prochaines
heures prochains jours par contre même
si un cessez le feu
on revient au point de départ un lieu
rien qui régler la situation des deux
millions de gazaouis actuellement qui
vivent dans une toute petite bande de
terre dans le sud d'israël à la
frontière avec l'egypte
leur situation reste la même la
situation des israéliens qui vivent dans
le sud d'israël entre aux tâches kelowna
judo d'hydro des petites villes
frontalières reste la même donc il va
quand même falloir trouver des solutions
pour régler conflit sinon sous peu dans
quelques mois quelques années ça va
reprendre encore parce que le tout ce
que ray israël aurait réussi à faire
c'est de diminuer l'arsenal du hamas
mais ça se reconstruit avait condamné
cet effet depuis la dernière guerre de
tous les analystes qui attendaient
justement ce la question s'ils sont très
pessimistes et andré le tilt que
l'avenir de ce conflit le gp une
résolution le en vue l'université assez
sombre comme comme à venir le c'est
comme si automatiser les deux côtés ont
des demandes mais aucun n'est prêt à
plier jamais vraiment cessé un pic
sports - les deux camps veulent les
mêmes choses se sont un peu le problème
c'est à dire que les deux jérusalem à
l'israélien disent que jérusalem c'est
leur capitale éternelle et indivisible
les palestiniens voudraient bien voir
jérusalem est comme capitale
alors que cette portion l'est de
jérusalem est occupée par israël depuis
la guerre de 1967
et ça c'est une occupation illégale
selon le droit international parce qu'en
plus israël il ya installe des colons
dans cette portion de la ville donc
d'israéliens qui vont vivre là en
territoire occupé
ensuite les israéliens veulent aussi
continuer la colonisation dans le grand
israël en ce qui ce qu on appelle ça la
judée samarie mais c'est la cisjordanie
donc continue d'installer des colons y
en a 400 milles en cisjordanie 200
milles à jérusalem est alors que les
palestiniens eux veulent un état ce soit
sur ce territoire là et plusieurs
palestine ils vont même aller plus loin
demandent que leur état soit installé
sur la palestine mandataire donc sur le
territoire actuel d'israël
donc ce sont des positions qui sont
attirés comme celle thème en
réconciliant puis comme tu le dis depuis
les accords d'oslo après la première
intifada 93 les pas grand-chose qui
avance et finalement une droitisation du
gouvernement israélien il ya eu trois
guerres puis peut-être une quatrième je
sais pas quand on va dire que maintenant
c'est une guerre entre israël et gaza et
donc eu 3 3 gars plusieurs escalade
donc c'est vrai que l'espoir l'espoir
est plus là autant pour les screenings
pour les palestiniens
pour comprendre la nature du conflit
puis pourquoi est ce que on est dans
cette impasse le je pense que autant
pour moi que pour les autres tant je
pense qu'on devrait reculer un petit peu
pour voir comment ce que si ces forces
là se sont placés en actions pour qu'on
en arrive ou est-ce qu'on est là quel a
été le point de départ attendu cette
histoire la pression pourra rentrer plus
dans certains détails puis pour me
montrer mais mais juste que je pense que
c'est important de juste reculé il
décide bien saisir ce bien plus c'est
lui justement de luxe d'avoir le temps
parce que justement souvent montrer
qu'il tient qu'on entend dans les médias
c'est par exemple à tout moment pas le
cas c'était à nice dur de quitter le
hadid n'a pas le temps de tony stone en
arrière pour porter les chronologies
mais l'on aurait le temps accusé le fun
ii d'essayer de comprendre parce que je
l'impression que la perception populaire
des personnes qui est qui qui qui qui
suppose de proches qui prouve vraiment
l'intérêt à faire le tri ont
l'impression qu'ils utilisent au rabais
c'est une région que ça tout le temps d
comme sur pino nanan titre tandis que ça
serait intéressant de savoir vraiment
exactement de conflit c'est qu'il est
ainsi pourquoi on manque de temps dans
les médias en général pour faire ça donc
c'est vrai que ce podcast c'est vraiment
l'endroit idéal pour pouvoir entre
essayé d'expliquer déplier un peu ce
point parce que plusieurs couches
il ya de nombreux événements qui ont
mené à cette nouvelle escalade de
violence on remonte si on veut il ya un
mois au début du ramadan mi-avril en
train de fonds ce qui se passe dans le
quartier de cheikh jarrah c'est un
quartier palestinien de jérusalem est
qui situé
à un jet de pierre c'est pas un mauvais
jeu de mots de la porte de damas
donc ça c'est l'entrée principale pour
les palestine et musulmans dans la ville
de jérusalem c'est un quartier où vivent
des palestiniens et où plusieurs
familles palestiniennes sont menacés
d'éviction au profit des colons
israéliens
c'est à dire qu'il ya des israéliens qui
veulent revenir vivre dans ce quartier
en disant moi en 1948
j'ai été chassé de jérusalem est ce qu a
eu la guerre israélo arabe qui a suivi
la création de l'état d'israël donc
selon les israéliens ils ont droit au
retour dans leur maison le problème
c'est que c'est pas nécessairement les
descendants des propriétaires qui
veulent revenir le des organisations
juives financés par différents groupes
dans le monde qui achète des maisons
pour réinstaller des israéliens juifs là
où ils étaient avant 48
l'autre problème vous diront les
palestine et c'est pas mon opinion mais
bien celle des palestine et c'est que
c'est pas vrai le droit au retour pour
les palestiniens qui eux ont été chassés
lors de la création de l'état d'israël
en quand israël a été créé s'en est
suivie une guerre qu'on appelle la
guerre israélo arabe en 1948 49
il ya 750 mille palestine et qui ont été
forcés à l'exil
c'est palestine et l'ont pas droit au
retour en israël parce que cela
menacerait l'existence même d'un état
juif
alors si ce qui se passe à sheikh jarrah
et les israéliens vous diront que c'est
simplement indifférents immobilier que
ce sont des familles palestiniennes qui
refusent de payer leur loyer dans des
bâtiments qui a personne qui
appartiennent à des organisations juives
c'est pas seulement un différend
immobilier on sait très bien que ça fait
partie d'une volonté affichée de l'état
d'israël de poursuivre la colonisation
c'est-à-dire de mettre ou de faire vivre
d'installer des israéliens par exemple à
jérusalem est ce qui est occupée ou même
en cisjordanie il s'en cache paul c'est
pas une question d'opinion personnelle
que je vous partage c'est ça benyamin
netanyahou le premier ministre israélien
le dit à plusieurs reprises qu'il allait
poursuivre la colonisation entre autres
en cisjordanie donc c'est ce qui se
passe à sheikh jarrah et eu pas mal de
mobilisation il ya eu des palestiniens
évidemment mais aussi des israéliens de
gauche qui sont venus soutenir les
palestiniens
donc depuis plusieurs semaines ça ça se
tramait il y avait une décision de la
cour suprême l'audience qui devait se
tenir et donc la pression monte et donc
eu des manifestations qui ont été
durement réprimées par la police
israélienne
je te dis juste peut-être peut-être que
pour une mise en contexte s'avère
intéressante aux digues et des
israéliens de gauche qui sont allés à
appuyer les palestiniennes dans ce conte
dans le début de ce conflit immobilier
en game est là quelle est la place des
désirs alliés de gauche dans la
politique israélienne en soi et ça c'est
une grande question c'est super
intéressant
le camp de la gauche ou le camp de la
paix et en délitement total depuis de
nombreuses années entre autres depuis la
mort l'assassinât de yitzhak rabin qui
était le premier ministre australien 95
l'israélien de golf sont rares sont très
très rares ça prend beaucoup de courage
pour aller à l'encontre si on veut de la
majorité dans son pays la jeunesse
israélienne et tu m'as vraiment en
accord avec les actions de l'état
je vous dirais que si tu me demandes la
majorité je dirais que oui oui oui tout
à fait israël
en israël le
service militaire est obligatoire autant
pour les hommes que pour les femmes donc
toi par exemple citer israélien doit
faire 2 ans et 8 mois de service
militaire obligatoire et que c'était une
femme ses deux ans suppose et la
présence la prison exactement il ya une
minorité d'ailleurs qu'une le qui
refusent le faire on les appelle les
refuzniks sous les objecteurs où les
objectis de conscience et beaucoup des
femmes et donc ça c'est extrêmement
difficile parce que tu te fais traiter
de traître par des voisins par ta
famille par tes amis parfois tu as du
mal à trouver un emploi après parce que
ta position dans l'armée israélienne
c'est important pour ton cv site a
réussi à accomplir des choses pendant
son service militaire
ça te permet de décrocher parfois des
bons emplois et donc pour revenir à la
question sur sheikh jarrah il ya des
israéliens de gauche qui sont là mais
c'est ça reflète une minorité sont venus
en israël mais en a il y en a il ya
entre autres des ong de gauche en israël
qui sont très très fortes
je pense par exemple à b tselem haye et
je dîne qui travaillent sur ces
questions-là de colonisation et tu
parlais de différents immobilisme c'est
vraiment un enjeu de colonisation à
jérusalem donc je reprenais le lait
narratif la formulation est donc et donc
ils sont là et se mobilisent et tous ces
gens là vont être réprimé les
manifestations vont être réprimés par la
police israélienne
parallèlement à celui requis ce qui se
passe en train de fond là à quelques à
15 minutes a pis on veut delà de la
porte de damas puis on est pendant le
ramadan est une tradition pendant le
ramadan les jeunes les femmes les
enfants vont s'asseoir dans les marches
de la porte de damas est comme un agora
son voeu et après l'iftar que leur repas
pour briser le jaune les jeunes se
rassemblent ils prennent des boissons
énergisantes et fument des cigarettes
ils se parlent
du coup je l' ai vécu plusieurs fois
afin de red bull la baule et
[Rires]
wii party prennent de l'alcool ah ouais
c'est donc moi j'ai souvent vu des
beaucoup de vendeurs qui se promènent en
disant ex el bared excellent bar est un
excellent la boisson énergisante bleus
froide donc inventer des trucs qu'on
entend puis ça reste en tête après que
l'on revient six cd des formulations qui
reste en tête et donc ils se réunissent
le h à canet donc hélas cette année la
police israéliennes décident de mettre
des barrières et d'empêcher les
rassemblements
c'est dessus sous prétexte de covin wii
wii fit si en fait oui et non la coved a
le dos large
on sait que en israël la grande majorité
d'israéliens sont vaccinés maintenant le
plus de problème de ce côté-là
côté palestinien c'est pas le cas par
exemple vraiment c'est vraiment une
infime minorité qui vacciner il sera là
pas trop l'air de s'en soucier
sauf pour les travailleurs palestiniens
qui viennent en israël ça ça peut être
un problème
donc ils ont pas dit que c'était pour la
copie de par contre qu'est donc
on peut penser que c'est peut-être pour
ça mais à chaque année à des tensions
je veux dire même que vide pas qu'on
vide dans les dernières années
vers 22h 22h30 quand tu passes par la
porte de damas et le ramada les
rassemblements de gens de palestine et
sont dispersés à coup de grenades
assourdissantes
mon l'avoir vu vécu des enfants avec des
petites filles avec des belles petites
robes et des mamans des garçons avec des
ballons peu importe ce qui se passe
c'est que le moins de l'est sap est que
les gens sont obligés de partir ça tue
le tue le vécu son année la fois la
dispersion policière april sais comment
c'est donc le pouls du moment de cirque
un quand ça arrive c'est dessus est ce
que c'est la panique générale est ce que
c'est juste le monde se disperse
c'est la panique générale quand est ce
qu'on appelle des stands grenade est
vraiment des grenades assourdissantes
quand ça pète ça fait vraiment fort si
tu leur soit près de la tête là c'est un
gros boum situe le reçoit sur la tête tu
pètes blessé gravement
non non ça surprend mais finalement ça
surprend parfois c'est lancer
directement dans la foule aussi ça
j'allais vu en couvrant les
manifestations en 2017 où on tirait
directement dans la foule aussi donc des
gens qui sont blessés à ce moment là
oui les gens se dispersent un peu dans
la panique puis évidemment toujours des
palestine et qui vont surtout les jeunes
qui vont rester pour résister qui vont
lancer des bouteilles des pierres sur la
police
parfois aussi on n'est pas à armes
égales
c'est la police israélienne qui est très
très armés armés de m16 par exemple même
si ce n'est pas l'armée israélienne
parce qu'en jérusalem jérusalem c'est la
police des frontières
ce n'est pas l'armée qui est à jérusalem
est donc même et c'est à s'y méprendre
parce que les policiers sont armés comme
un soluté comme des zelda finalement ils
ont des grenades assourdissantes des gaz
lacrymogènes
les palestiniens eux mêmes ce qu'ils
trouvent sous la main des pierres des
bouteilles
ça peut être parfois aussi les
palestiniens qui qui lance le bal en
lançant une bouteille par exemple sur un
groupe de deux policiers israéliens
ça arrive je prendrais dire que son
inverse ça arrive ça parce que pendant
le ramadan une espèce de petite
excitation aussi l'otan ils ont un rush
de sucre après avoir été agent unique
seul froid exactement robin directeur
non mais ça aussi qu'il faut dire que
pour les palestiniens et la police
israélienne ce une police d'occupation
donc c'est paul est pas la police à
montréal qui patrouillent la police
communautaire mois maintenir l'ordre
pour eux c'est vu comme l'occupant faut
pas oublier qu'il ya aussi dans la tête
des palestine et donc se sait tout ça
mis ensemble des petites escarmouches à
gauche à droite qui a fait monter une
tension qui a mené sa d'abord ça s'est
déplacé sur l'esplanade des mosquées
parce que là c'est le ramadhan dernier
vendredi du ramadan il ya parfois
jusqu'à deux cent cinquante mille
personnes sur l'esplanade des mosquées
de l'esplanade des mosquées
c'est tout petit c'est un petit
rectangle de territoire dans la vieille
ville de jérusalem dans le quartier
musulman de la vieille ville fait un
kilomètre carré
ça vous donne une idée à quel point ces
petits et donc de 150000 personnes qui
se réunissent sur l'esplanade c'est
énorme mais cette année ils ont mis des
limites sur le nombre de personnes et
donc le vendredi du ramadan
il ya eu des heurts entre sur
l'esplanade entre policiers israéliens
et
des palestine et des fidèles qui
allaient prier la ce a dégénéré donc
d'un côté balles en caoutchouc gaz
lacrymogènes de l'autre bouteilles en
verre pierre ça dégénère
la police entre dans la mosquée al aqsa
qui est le troisième lieu saint pour les
musulmans
donc c'est une mosquée très importante
il entre à l'intérieur et lancent des
grenades assourdissantes à l'intérieur
c'est rare que ça arrive c'est ça c'est
pas c'est rare mais ça s'est déjà vu
mais c'est vraiment une ligne rouge pour
les palestiniens ne pas franchir donc
l'attention beaucoup monté puis a eu
trois jours de violences comme ça ça
fait plus de 500 morts avait pas de pot
ça sera marc parent dont 700 blessés
palestine et est donc le lundi
il y avait comme à chaque année une
marche les israéliens appellent ça y'est
mirauchaux line donc le jour de
jérusalem
eux ils célèbrent la prise de jérusalem
pendant la guerre des six jours selon le
calendrier hébraïque c'était ce lundi là
cette date là et à chaque année à des
groupes de juifs extrémistes qui
viennent défiler dans la vieille ville
de jérusalem comme une provocation son
maître que c'est perçu comme une
provocation par les permanences une
seule célébration le way exactement et
donc le lundi
la marche est prévue la tension est déjà
à son comble alors le encore d'ailleurs
sur l'esplanade les organisateurs
décident d'annuler officiellement la
marche
mais quand même des groupes des
groupuscules de jeunes juifs extrémistes
qui se rassemblent et le hamas dit la
marque est à gaza d'ailleurs assez un
territoire qui est géographiquement
séparés donc la masse qui dit qui a
convaincu vraiment être à peu près 90 km
à vol d'oiseau la masse qui dit la cie à
18 heures la police israélienne n'a pas
quitté l'esplanade des mosquées
on va réagir et ils ont tenu leur
promesse faite le lion lancer des
missiles puis elle a commencé
ça a commencé comme ça ils ont lancé des
roquettes vers jérusalem cette requête
c'est extrêmement rare l'art jérusalem
c'est déjà arrivé une fois quand j'étais
l'homme et les syriens n'avais pas
ressenti à ce moment là cette fois ci
les sirènes ont retenti dans jérusalem
ça c'était quand même inédit depuis très
très longtemps
il a pas eu de blessé pas une mort non
plus dans ses lancers de roquettes
il y avait des des vidéos de palestine
et qui ont beaucoup circulé des
palestiniens qu'ils étaient ça va être
difficile à comprendre mais qu'ils
étaient contents de voir que le hamas de
lancer des roquettes sur jérusalem alors
que les roquettes d'une sève véreux
finalement mais ils ont eu le sentiment
que pour une fois quelqu'un se lever
pour eux et que c'était le hamas à gaza
parce que aussi un vide politique on
prend reparler plus tard dans l'été
palestine et est donc et donc ça se
passe
et puis c'est aussi une ligne rouge pour
israël et donc israël a évidemment
bombardé des cibles à gaza
et dès le début il ya une vingtaine de
morts dont plusieurs enfants et donc ça
la marche n'avait pas choix aussi de
réagir en est donc là évidemment c'est
un engrenage puis décapité et londres
est de cette crise le sait qui est ici
c'est un conflit en deux et hommes sauf
que les gens les victimes de tous et
lille si les citoyens qui sont leurs
pieds qui ont rien demander puisque son
pot et qui sont pas les seuls qui sont
juste loupe qui sont qui sautent en
mauvaise passe en ce moment c'est celle
qu'on grandisse l'est qui ont vécu qui
écope de ceux de ce crime entrisme c'est
pas un conflit entre deux états dans la
mesure où et oui israël tu es un état
mais les palestine et la palestine ce
n'est pas un état monsieur abbas quand
même qu'il lui donne exactement c'est ça
mais je tiens à préciser parce que les
palais ce n'est si ce qu'ils voudraient
avoir un état indépendant c'est leurs
revendications mais euh en fait vivent
dans des territoires palestiniens de la
palestine parfois pour simplifier plus
parce que la palestine ça représente un
groupe de personnes d'une culture ou
s'il ya une région mais c'est pas un
pays
ils vivent dans un dans des territoires
qui sont occupés actuellement par israël
mais donc mais tu as raison
peu importe notre opinion politique ce
sont des civils
une sauce qui fait le lit et dans cette
escalade là actuellement beaucoup
d'enfants le quart des enfants le quart
des victimes à gaza sont des enfants je
veux dire c'est très pro c'est très
troublant c'est tout
c'est chaud quand même on peut le dire
c'est choquant les images qui ont
circulé sur les réseaux sociaux étaient
horribles les témoignages étaient
horribles aussi une mère qui dit par
exemple qui va finalement qui passent la
nuit dans la chambre de ses enfants
parce que le dinar gazaouis qui dit si
une bombe qui tombe sur notre maison
mais je converse et tous ensemble je
peux faire le deuil de mes enfants s'est
prononcée prenant lui-même côté
israélien aussi il ya eu deux enfants
sur les douze victimes donc des victimes
collatérales soit de roquettes qui sont
tombées à un endroit puis des éclats
d'obus
donc c'est pas plus drôle de ce côté là
bien sûr allez vous dirons nous nos
enfants
psychologiquement son sont traumatisés
de devoir courir d'un homme quand on
entend les alarmes de devoir courir aux
abris anti roquettes les palestine et
vous répondront oui mais nous on n'a pas
d'abri en tirant guette et me répondront
aussi mais nous on n'a pas le fameux
dôme de fer qui intègre qui intercepte
les roquettes certains israël au sud
d'israël et un système antimissile qui
intercepte 90% des roquettes qui
proviennent de gaza parce que évidemment
les gens gazon on peut un système pour
intercepter les bombes israéliennes
donc peu importe c'est la politique
finalement l'isra l'impie les
palestiniens sont foot l'homme sur le
terrain c'est eux qui paient le prix des
gens qui se retrouvent sans maison à
gaza un bilan humain qui est qui est
très élevé à des gens qui vont à une
blessée qui auront des conséquences à
long terme
ça nous permet de comprendre le tice
convient de faire la raison pourquoi
quelqu'un un retour aux hostilités et
puis aux attaques se met ça dérange pas
je vois ce qu'on vient encore plus en
arrière mais vraiment le type à ce que
je peux peut-être te poser des questions
qui pour toi te semble évidente mais
pour moi c'est l'épopée choquer pour
plein de gens c'est les pô juste mettons
les deux d'israël titre je pense que
c'est mentionné 48
ça c'est la date où les ltte d'israël
était crée évidemment pour que je me
trompe
selon nietzsche suite après la deuxième
guerre mondiale
je viens de vivre la pire atrocité puis
on crée c'est alors un peu pour leur
donner un genre de sanctions larges des
taux à 1
sauf que il ya des gens qui habitaient
sur ce territoire le psy j'imagine
l'origine du conflit de tous et ceux ci
il y avait des gens là on les a déplacés
pour pour créer un état pour les juifs
fouet puis puis comment ça s'est passé
en fait c'est super historienne le mais
je vous raconte un petit peu tu as
raison donc en 1948 les nations unies
adopte une résolution pour créer un pays
pour les juifs qui sont qui sont
massacrés en marché nos maux en europe
donc après la shoah qui a fait six
millions de morts faut dire que les
mouvements sionistes installé déjà des
juifs en palestine depuis la fin je
dirais du dix neuvième siècle donc cinq
mentionnés soucier le désir de retourner
à la terre c'est exactement est donc
déjà des gens qui revenaient là parce
que la persécution des juifs ans et
s'adapte ça se passait déjà bien avant
la seconde guerre mondiale donc
tranquillement avait quand même une plus
grande population juive avec les années
et en 48 effectivement on a créé on a
dit on va créer l'état d'israël à cet
endroit là et la résolution de l'onu
prévoyait un état pour les jeux fait un
pour les
les arabes ayant tracé sur une carte ont
dit qu'ils le disent non ici arabe ici
juifs ici et donc s'en est suivie une
guerre parce qu'évidemment que les
voisins les pays arabes autour on pas
accepter ça donc eu la guerre
israélo-arabe et là israël opus si sa
guerre d'indépendance finalement donc en
ils ont tracé des frontières de leur
pays
en fait c'est la ligne verte ce qu'on
appelle la ligne la fameuse ligne verte
dont c'est une ligne d'armistice de
1948-49 qui aujourd'hui c'est par
jérusalem ouest de la ligne verte
c'est exact c'est une autoroute
aujourd'hui mais surtout israël dans la
ligne 10 c'est encore me drai le que
pour deux côtés y'a pas de chèques
pointe entre les deux n'est vraiment
tout un monde qui les sépare l'on pourra
en reparler plus tard de comment ça se
passe à jérusalem concrètement on voit
très bien la différence entre jérusalem
et donc voilà une guerre et est
finalement israël voit son pays fonde
son pays en 1948 donc ça fait plus de
soixante dix ans après il ya plusieurs
guerres dans l'histoire du conflit
israélo palestinien mais y en a une qui
est qui a encore des conséquences
aujourd'hui c'est la guerre des six
jours en 1967 et donc c'est une bière
surprise les voisins d'israël entre
autres les gîtes la série attaque israël
et israël en séjour réussi je pense à
tripler si je me trompe pas sur le
territoire et donc et c'est là où ils
prennent le sinaï gaza le snav affirme
être donnés plus tard à l'egypte dans le
cadre d'un traité de paix mais le sinaï
gaza jérusalem est la cisjordanie
hélas à sa sage est un petit peu les
bases si on veut de du conflit
aujourd'hui c'est encore des
conséquences aujourd'hui plus de 50 ans
plus tard parce que les palestiniens
sont occupés depuis
depuis cette date avant cette attaque le
il y avait une relative paix dans dans
cette région le 2 49 n'ont rien donné
par exemple la gare de 57 il ya eu
d'autres conflits que tous les rues
toujours une position toujours une
tension
ouais tout à fait puisque c'est est-ce
que c'était sur des bases politiques
territoriales religieuse c'était quoi le
sens de ces conflits
ouais ça se mêlent un peu tout ce qu'on
veut ce conflit-là mêle un peu l'aspect
religieux territoriales je pense que des
gens qui font l'erreur de dire que c'est
la religion qui tous les juifs conclut
conclut musulmans par exemple je pense
que c'est faux je pense que c'est une
mauvaise lecture du conflit je pense que
c'est territoriales
mais évidemment que la religion vient
jouer euros parce que l'importance
jérusalem c'est parce que les trois
lieux saints pour les trois religions
donc évidemment que la religion vient
jouer un rôle mais aujourd'hui le
conflit les territoriales les ports
religieux le plusieurs israéliens juifs
qui vous le dirai moi j'ai pas de
problème à coexister avec un musulman
aucun chrétien parce que les
palestiniens sont majoritairement
musulmans mais quand même une partie de
la population qui est chrétienne
donc on parle des arabes donc cesser les
époques tous les musulmans et les
chrétiens et les musulmans et donc
dans un conflit qui est principalement
territoriales mais territoriale
considérant que le territoire est liée
en proximité avec l'origine d'actes mans
ouais ça s'entrecoupent toi lola est ce
que c'est l'importance de jérusalem en
tant que les marques religieux le jeu
dur c'est pas nouveau le lean croisade
si tu es seul tu y es ce kit est ce que
sa salle à cette espèce de kongolo
constant pour le territoire où est-ce
qu'ils s'étaient les chrétiens galère
chercher jérusalem après ce petit qui
avait tout ce conflit là autour de vie
rural m est ce que ça le salon poursuivi
dans le temps jusqu'à un espèce de
l'espèce de transformation jusqu'à ce
que ce qu'on a maintenant lily l'espèce
de de combat pour les lieux le tuer
c'est quelque chose qui qui qui a
toujours été le même avant même avant
qu'israël ne vient de naître
huawei est tout à fait il ya toujours eu
tout le monde c'est toujours arracher
finalement jérusalem à des époques -
d'autres époques davantage on tue le bim
expliqué sauf que aujourd'hui ce qu'il
faut comprendre de giral mc que la
vieille ville de jérusalem à compte
trois lieux saints de l'église du saint
sépulcre pour les chrétiens sur ça ça
fait moins l'objet de conflits mais
principalement l'esplanade des mosquées
qui est aussi appelé le mont du temple
par les juifs
ce qu'il me le même la même lieu dans le
fond exactement la même lieu sacré pour
pour les juifs et les arabes
ouais sur l'esplanade des mosquées à la
mosquée al aqsa qui est le troisième
lieu saint des musulmans après la mecque
et à médine en arabie saoudite
et je dois vous le dire et puis du du
côté de
des juifs le mur des lamentations qui
est un pan une fondation son voeu de
cette esplanade là et ça c'est le
premier lieu saint des juifs et donc
c'est tout petit tout se rend là vous
vous imaginez une esplanade ses immenses
non c'est long feuilleton rapidement à
piles donc et donc moi je vivais dans un
appartement qui était situé à 50 mètres
à vol d'oiseau du dôme du rocher ça
c'est pas la mosquée al aqsa et le dôme
du rocher le dôme doré le convoi sont
meilleures cartes postales bons essais
c'est juste à côté de la mosquée al aqsa
donc sûrement toi à qu'elle bouge pour
vous expliquer quel point ces petits on
voit à la fois le mur des lamentations
et la mosquée al-aqsa donc cesser tout
petits et parfois des palestiniens c'est
déjà arrivé qui ont lancé des pierres
sur les gens qui puissent prier au mur
des lamentations un bon bras quand même
mais bon c'est donc je vais vous allez
mieux ça ensuite jérusalem c'est aussi
la capitale revendiquée dès palestine
est en tout cas jérusalem est les
palestine et qui veulent avoir un pays
une palestine indépendante disent nous
on veut notre capitale dont jérusalem
est
les israéliens eux depuis qu'ils
occupent jérusalem est
il avait déjà jérusalem ouest depuis la
création de leur pays en 48 ans 67 ils
ont pris l'est en 80 l'ont annexe et ça
ça veut dire qu'ils ont mis la police au
lieu de l'armée donc c'est des lois
civiles depuis 80 qui gouverne cette
partie est de jérusalem et ils ont
réitéré que jérusalem c'était leur
capitale éternelle et indivisible s'est
pas reconnue par la communauté
internationale d'ailleurs c'est la
raison pour laquelle il ya toutes les
ambassades des pays dans le monde qui
sont à tel aviv
sauf récemment en 2018 donald trump
alors président américain qui a déplacé
son ambassade à jérusalem je sais pas si
vous vous en rappelez mai
ça a soulevé tout un tollé plusieurs
manifestations entre autres à gaza
d'ailleurs vous prend par les saf et des
morts plusieurs personnes parce que
c'est comme un symbole pour dire on
prend le vraiment la partie des iraniens
là dedans comme de dire que jérusalem
appartient c'est pro israélien on sait
que les états unis sont les alliés
traditionnels historique d'israël puis
donald trump disait on va de l'indre en
voulait à présenter un plan de paix pour
réussir à faire la paix entre israël et
palestine et donc il s'est dit on va
enlever jérusalem de la table des
négociations a donné jérusalem aux
israéliens donc les palestiniens ont dit
bah ça marche pas comme ça depuis
toujours la communauté internationale
les nations unies disent le statut de
jérusalem doit être négocié dans le
cadre des négociations de paix doit être
discutée dans le cadre des négociations
de paix on peut pas donner un parti ou
un autre et donc les israéliens disent
que c'est leur capital mais c'est pas la
position du canada et de la maj la
grande majorité des pays dans le monde
donc jérusalem est importante pour
toutes ces raisons là j'ai l'impression
que la communauté internationale regarde
les conflits puis personnes personne
n'est d'accord avec mettons-les les
décisions de l'état d'israël mais
personne ne fait rien j'ai l'impression
betty puis un versement aussi jeudi à la
marsa prévention sont son côté de talent
mais j'ai l'impression qu'on regarde le
conflit mais qui parce que rien en fait
puisque somme dépassant dre de on fait
juste assisté à comme ces deux peuples
qui qui s'attaquent qui s'entretuent
mais qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce qui freine
en fait avec me détends salle des
tertiales de deux ans chez ba c'est une
bonne question israël est très puissant
au plan diplomatique entre autres donc
ce qu'on a vu dans les derniers jours
mais aussi c'est comme ça chaque
escalade
la diplomatie internationale c'est
toujours des tweets en anglais que 18h10
plis concerned qui nous c'est presque
une vie presque devenu une blague on
sait à chaque fois qu'ils vont dire la
même chose
nous sommes très préoccupés par
l'escaladé des violences
nous condamnons les violences dans les
deux camps rarement les pays vont
condamner l'utilisation excessive de la
force par exemple par israël à gaza
il ya des pays de l'union européenne
qu'ils ont fait cette fois ci mais le
canada l'a pas fait souvent j'ai tout ça
c'est quelque chose qui était qui
revient souvent l'espèce de maisons de
l'asymétrie bad asymétrie entre les
forces présentes tout à fait et est donc
la majorité des pays qui vont ce qu'ils
vont dire c'est que ils reconnaissent le
droit d'israël de se défendre contre les
roquettes du hamas qu'il reconnaisse le
droit d'occuper d'état quitté pau
qui était pas destiné à rodez parce que
c'est son nom la communauté
internationale ne reconnaît pas
l'occupation israélienne dit d'ailleurs
pourquoi c'est encore une autre qu une
occupation israël
c'est toujours une question de point de
vue en israël pour israël c'est pas une
occupation
il sera elle n'aime pas qu'on dise le ce
sont des territoires occupés n'aime pas
qu'on utilise les mots colons pour
parler des israéliens qui vivent par
exemple en cisjordanie ou à jérusalem
est
le droit international dit donc comme
journaliste
parfois c'est un peu compliqué parce que
quel vocabulaire qui elle maudit
utilisent pour l'israélien le droit
international
ça vaut rien ou presque rien en tout cas
quand ça fait pas leur affaire
il le rejette une latéralement pour
l'israël et le droit international va
jamais assez loin donc nous comme
journal est souvent c'est notre ligne si
on veut de pour faire nos reportages
pour choisir le vocabulaire donc non
l'occupation n'est pas reconnue par la
communauté internationale israël dit
toujours on n'occupe pas l'été retour
c'est chez nous laisse sur cet argument
là ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il ya
des ong
entre autres israéliens de gauche comme
b'tselem qui va dire d'accord si vous
n'occupez pas les territoires palestine
et qu'est ce que c'est alors est ce que
c'est un apartheid
même si c'est chez vous c'est votre pays
mais que vous donnez pas les mêmes
droits à une catégorie de citoyens
est ce que c'est de la ségrégation moi
et ça évidemment qu'israël rejette ces
termes là et il ya une maintenance c'est
comme viacom plus de factures et rejette
tous les termes c'est bizarre c'est
difficile de se positionner louis et
donc human rights watch a publié un
rapport récemment qui disait qu israël
est un état qui qui faisait de
l'apartheid entrons dans un territoire
occupé
et ça ça a été vraiment vraiment dénoncé
par israël
ça dépend ça dépend vraiment des points
de vue le moi je vous partage des
arguments que j'entends dans les deux
camps soient ce ne sont pas du tout mes
arguments mais mais c'est ce qu'on
entend le sur le terrain de la part des
différents acteurs
mais il ya eu des sanctions battante
mettons économiquement c'est où
boutih les actions qui sont faites pour
essayer dé reculer ou ben justement lic
les ans tantôt tellement forte qu'ils
sont tellement bénéfique et aux alliés
d'israël que yo que jamais personne qui
tape sur les doigts un train peu très
peu
il ya un mouvement qui s'appelle bds
donc boycott désinvestissement et
sanctions qui réussit parfois faire
quelques coups d'éclat mais dans les
faits le boycott économique par exemple
d'israël n'ont réussi pas avoir d effet
il serait elle est peut-être trop fort
dans sa diplomatie
ça reste un allié des états unis
les etats unis qui financent à coups de
milliards d'ailleurs l'armée israélienne
dont israël en général heureusement dire
qu'ils financent indirectement le
conflit actuel
peut-être si vous le dites
responsabilité mais qu'est-ce qui ont
garni enfin financer l'armée israélienne
c'est un allié c'est des joueurs qui se
font entre différents pays c'est de se
déverser des milliards de dollars pour
un d'israël à se défendre près de ryad
et serait las positionner parce qu'il
n'ya pas que les palestiniens israël
bombarde aussi parfois au liban bombe
parfois aussi en syrie ce sont tous des
pays voisins est donc une question
géopolitique leur antre parce que tu
sais il ya une contradiction mais je
pense que yard donne 10 et c'est qui qui
qui en appelle à justement la réduction
de conflit pour mais on dirait que la
coulisse ça ça c'est pas ça du tout ce
que dubai dernière mercredi c'était il
appela la désescalade en vue d'un cessez
le feu
ça c'est au dixième jour de l'escaladé
actuelle ce que ça veut dire c'est le
débit finalement bbc le surnom de
benyamin nétanyahou
comme joe joe biden c'est joseph bon
mais c'est en fait on dit la même chose
à ces paquets rien c'est pas moi qui
allais pour pas dire son nom combler
tout le temps on l'appelle bilan non non
c'est vraiment les mêmes les gens
s'aiment et label bbc même trempe appelé
benyamin nétanyahou bibi donc bon comme
journaliste formule est formellement le
deal je le dis pas d'habitude à
l'antenne mais donc je sais pas je
l'emmenais avec bill a oui donc c'est
comme si joe biden disait habib sy
écoute je te laisse encore un petit peu
de temps pour finir le travail à gaza
mais lol bien tout ça me fait mal
paraître il faudrait quand même que tu
arrêtes les bombardements essayé de
sauter au dixième jour seulement de l'
escalade après avoir empêché le conseil
de sécurité de l'onu d'adopter une
motion et des lignes ont été les seuls à
dire non à cette motion la loi ils ont
fait bande à part et donc c'est comme si
joe biden avait été très silencieux dans
les derniers jours pour permettre à
israël de faire ce qu'il avait à faire
dans la bande de gaza une expression
aussi qui dit tondre le gazon c'est à
dire qu' il serait à elle une fois de
temps en temps après quelques années
tout le gazon à gaza puis va être bon
encore pour quelques années c'est à dire
diminue les capacités militaires de la
branche armée du hamas
on va après on garde le statu quo on
laisse ça comme ça dans quelques années
on recommence pour éviter qu'ils amènent
une force trop grande qui deviennent
menaçante
or israël mais déjà le hamas avait
réussi à renflouer son arsenal depuis la
dernière guerre de 2014 impressionnant
on l'a vu dans le nombre de roquettes
qui ont été tirées tirées sur israël en
seulement quelques jours c'est plus que
le nombre de roquettes au total dans la
guerre de 2014 qui a duré 50 jours puis
qu'est-ce qui finance le hawzi l'iran
principalement c'est l'iran qui apporte
aussi son savoir faire pour la
fabrication d'armes
c'est fabriqué principalement à gaza il
y avait avant des armes qui étaient
transité par des tunnels à la frontière
avec l'egypte maintenant les tunnels
l'arrivée au pouvoir de fattah al-sisi
en egypte qui est pas issu des frères
musulmans alors que la hamas c'est une
branche de certaines branches des frères
musulmans donc fatale ceci qui est moins
amis si on veut avec la masse a choisi
d'inonder les tunnels du côté de sa
frontière donc la mort ça beaucoup moins
tunnel maintenant donc l'iran les
gardiens de la révolution ont des
ingénieurs qui transmettent leur savoir
faire à des gazaouis qui huaient
fabrique sur place le des roquettes et
d'autres armes
c'est quoi c'est quoi mettons le
scénario où il y aurait une résolution
du conflit est ce que ce serait
reconnaître un état palestinien était
indépendante sous avec tout les pouvoirs
que ça que ça apporte avec eux justement
un territoire qui fait crédit sans se
piquer à se respecter ou du côté
israélien est ce que ce soit que c'est
un eto'o ou palestinien cohabiter - la
première option est probable plus de 25
ans après l'échec des accords d'oslo
l'oeil la solution qui était prôné
c'était la solution à deux états donc un
état juif à côté d'un état palestinien
c'est de moins en moins possible
principalement à cause de la
colonisation
donc à cause du nombre d'israéliens qui
vivent en ce moment à jérusalem est et
en cisjordanie c'est plus de 600000 même
site près de 650 mille aujourd'hui
comment construire un état palestinien
sur un territoire qui morcelé pour bien
comprendre le conflit israélo
palestinien il faut regarder les cartes
et quand on regarde une carte dans les
accords d'oslo
on a déterminé trois types de zones et
ça c'est important je pense à comprendre
en cisjordanie parce que forment une
majorité de palestiniens qui vivent le
lait les ondes ab c'est donc d'abord
toutes les grandes villes palestiniennes
ramallah naplouse jénine par exemple
saison a donc vous pouvez vous imaginer
une carte avec des petits points ça
c'est comme des îles si on veut dans une
mer l'eau qui serait la cisjordanie
ces zones ah ça veut dire que c'est sous
contrôle civil et militaire de
l'autorité palestinienne donc l'autorité
palestienne qui étaient créés pendant
les accords d'oslo d'ailleurs les
accords d'oslo qui visait un jour à
créer un état pour les palestiniens un
accord de paix tous on ne crée
l'autorité palestinienne en vue de soi
finalement il s'est rien passé mais bon
les trois zones sont encore là
aujourd'hui il ya la zone b donc tout
autour de ces dix points lors qu'ils
sont on a lieu la zone b ça c'est des
pouvoir partager civile pouvoir civil
pour l'autorité palestinienne mais
militaire pour la miss rennes et tout le
reste la cisjordanie le lamer finalement
autour de ces îles la saison c'est ça
représente 60% de la cisjordanie c'est
là où se trouvent les colonies et des
villages palestiniens aussi c'est
contrôlée à 100% par l'armée israélienne
cela dit dans les zones à l'armée
israélienne font des raids parfois quand
même ça empêche pas d'entrer en zone à
même si c'est officiellement sous
contrôle de l'autorité palestinienne
puisse aussi ce qui est devenu au fil du
temps où était dessinée comme ceux au
départ oui les occasions non mais le
d'alphonse de saison de ce que je
comprends la lfh on sait que c'est pas à
gauche les noms palestinienne ligne puis
à droite ici par carte il est faussé par
un petit îlot où est ce que le seuil est
ce si un quartier palestinien il
carrément belle sauf que tout autour 6
rallier donc c'est pas clair comme il ya
une frontière une frontière saison-là
devait être temporaire
sauf que le problème c'est que ça fait
25 ans pin qui a bougé
et pendant ce temps là la colonisation
elle s'est accélérée
donc il n'est pas 600 mille colons à
l'époque y en avait peut-être mais il
avait beaucoup moins ça c'est beaucoup
accéléré donc là aujourd'hui on se dit
comment on va gérer ça est-ce qu'on
laisse les colons par exemple les
israéliens vivent dans un état
palestinien je pense pas qu'il accepte
ça est ce qu'on essaie de par exemple
prendre certaines grandes colonies les
annexer à israël faire des échanges de
territoire c'est un peu ce qui était
prévu dans le plan de paix de présenter
par le gendre de donald trump jared
kushner ça peut être une possibilité
mais quand on regarde les quartiers
compliqué les palestiniens ont pote
territoire ont pas de continuité dans
leur territoire et pour lier la
cisjordanie à gaza
faudrait construire
un genre de tunnels ou pour un pont
aérien je pense pas que ce soit réaliste
mao tunnel pour lier les deux
territoires qui ne sont pas liées
actuellement sont à une cinquantaine de
kilomètres à peu près mis à israël entre
les deux non mais c'est ça c'est comme
si on dirait qu'on est dangereux qui
tacle ben je pense que beaucoup de monde
directement s'ils sont dans un cul de
sac actuellement même les palestiniens
eux mêmes n'ont plus aucun espoir
le leader mahmoud abbas donc le
président de l'autorité palestinienne
ont pas fait grand chose depuis qu'il a
été élu pour les palestiniens c'est ce
que vous diront les palestiniens la
colonisation quand même c'est quand même
accéléré et continue de collaborer avec
israël pour ce qu'ils appellent la
coordination sécuritaire pour déjouer
certaines tentatives d' attaque donc
c'est comme si les palestiniens télé
c'est un même puis ils ont fait un bon
vieux d'argile à un peu ce n'est pas une
dictature le luxe c'est une élection qui
était dans les règles de l'art
lorsqu'il n'ya pas eu d'élection depuis
15 ans c'est ça donc d'abord les
palestiniens accusent de corruption
il s'accroche au pouvoir
ça ça fait partie d'ailleurs des causes
de cette escalade là il n'ya pas eu
d'élection depuis quinze ans il devait y
avoir une élection dès qu'elle date le
20 et le 22 mai il devait y avoir une
élection palestine ça est annulé par
mahmoud abbas que dit israël ne nous
laisse pas tenir nos élections à
jérusalem est
donc on annuler à cause de ça en vérité
mahmoud abbas ça faisait peut-être un
petit peu son affaire parce que la masse
est assez populaire en cisjordanie
est-ce qu'ils auraient réussi à avoir un
autre mandat beaucoup de personnes en
doute
donc là vu qu'un vide politique côté
palestinien c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle le hamas en a profité quand ils
ont vu ce qui se passe à jérusalem abbas
était pas mal silencieux ils ont dit
nous on va se présenter comme les
défenseurs de jérusalem et des palestine
et et de la cause palestinienne et c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont lancé des roquettes
sur jérusalem
j'ai quand même l'impression titre du
palais des sports tantôt libération puis
des sports pitt et après ce petit israël
utilise le prétexte la légitime défense
heureusement pour pour justifier le tcc
actions peu pitié on accuse mettons la
marre d'être une organisation terroriste
le choléra mais quand tu enlève tout
espoir un peuple
qu'est ce tu pense qu'il va retrouver le
tien catalyse tout territoire
tu essaies de petite fille enlève
justement tout toute chose à quelque peu
jeu se projeter dans l'avenir le tipi
qui sait sur qui va avoir une
radicalisation qui va avoir des gens qui
vont qui vont qui vont prendre les armes
c'est juste normal quand aucun espoir
ta seule option la seule manière de 40
ans et ce c'est ce qui va arriver c'est
sauf que j'ai l'impression qu'ils les
palestiniens plus coriaces je me trompe
en demande au final pas tant que
danseuse qui s'en retourne dans le passé
l'idée satellisant c'est de céder ses
parts habiter ces territoires le thé
clos maintenant ce qui demanderait je
pense c'est juste une fraction de ce que
ce qui au départ le t2 d'avoir jérusalem
c est dans leur queue puis d'avoir un
eto'o puis pouvoir vivre en tant que
nation ont noté une somme que c'est pas
un si gros compromis afin de vous
rallier pour josé on va arrêter une fois
pour toutes
je comprends pas qu'on n'est pas capable
d'arriver à ce contenu
entre les pressions qu'ils les dames ans
ont fait que ceci ouais l'espagne vous
diront pas ça ils vont trouver que les
d'amendé palestine et sont effectivement
excessive pour les israéliens ils
veulent un eretz israël donc un grand
israël sur ce que ce que appelle la
judée samarie donc la cisjordanie
[Musique]
ils ont ils ont des visées bien au delà
de leurs frontières actuelles donc puis
si si pour toi tu est la capitale et à
capitale indivisible
c'est quand même moi mais par le chef
pour l'autre aussi dans la caisse pour
sa manucure tout avoir la vie ne sont
pas prêts à laisser jérusalem est aux
palestiniens parce que pour eux
jérusalem est où se trouve d'ailleurs le
mur des lamentations c'est leur premier
lieu 5
ils veulent pas perdre le contrôle là
dessus est-ce qu'on pourrait pas trouver
par exemple une solution je sais pas moi
la vieille ville où même la ville de
jérusalem entière géré par une entité
autre que qui sera éliminé bon peut-être
mais je pense pas qu'il sera signé on
veut laisser le contrôle à quiconque
sera sur la ville avec dalphond jeu une
fois qu'on est face à face avec ce mur
loupé cette espèce de cul-de-sac qu'on
parle depuis tout à l'heure où est ce
qu'ils semblent pas avoir de solution à
l'interné est ce que c est ce que la
solution serait pas d'un l'ingérence de
la communauté nationale
ce qu'a dit fx à la communauté nationale
qui qui viendraient établir par exemple
comme tu dis jérusalem comme étant un
état en tant que tel géré par un tierce
partie qui
qui accepte ou qu'ils s'assurent que
tout ce règne dans le bonheur et la joie
lé sait mais parce que mettons qu'on
puis en même temps je me dis c'est pas
la place nécessairement des autres pays
d'intervenir danseurs sûr que si 1 6t
sans harnais delà de la paix mondiale ça
m'apparaît comme la seule solution qui
ont un potentiel de régler la situation
ça a déjà été discutée après je sais pas
ça c'est un peu d'abord et avec le temps
là on est en train de refaire le monde
du 6 mai c'est à montréal ça ça paraît
évident que ce soit la solution
je ne sais pas si c'est réaliste d'un
effet si ce sera acceptée par les deux
cas baisse probable maintenant c'est sûr
que non et c'est pour ça que je dis
peut-être que s'il s'est d'être l'un
posée mais encore là c'est fou de penser
seul alors que c'est pas ça a participé
à tour leur appartient pas au mieux
intentionnés mais en même temps dans des
mesures de guerre
les communautés essentielle des fois
interviennent même quand ça les regarde
pas tant que ça mais jérusalem ouest et
considérées de facto
il sera aidé la majorité des pays vous
diront effectivement jérusalem-ouest ça
fait partie du sport
ils le disent pas publiquement mais bon
les personnes qui s'obstine là dessus
parce que ça fait partie des frontières
de 48 49 parce que c'est pas vraiment
revendiquée par les palestiniens
quoi qu'il ya des groupes palestiniens
comme le hamas qui parle jérusalem comme
une entité aussi là mais au moins
jérusalem est en tout cas c'est ce qui
est revendiqué par l'autorité
palestinienne d'avoir de pouvoir avoir
sa capitale dans jérusalem-est dans le
plan de pétrole
on prévoyait à bout disque est comme une
banlieue de jérusalem points
intéressants du tout c'est surprenant de
penser qu'ils ont que les américains ont
pensé que les palestiniens à accepter ça
évidemment que ça a été rejetée du
revers de la main tout à habiter
jérusalem pendant combien de temps 4 à
nankin 2016 2020
ouais ouais c'est cela je m'en allais
aussi tout tu travaillais pour atout
quand 2,5 me permets tu as décidé
d'aller ça a été plus que j'ai travaillé
à radio canada saguenay-lac-saint-jean
entre 2005 et 2013 où j'ai tout appris
du journalisme vraiment choisi de la
radio de la télé tu es tu allé toucher
studio jean clouet gfa tm
après je suis parti à travailler dans
ces années là pour venir faire mon bac à
montréal je retournais là-bas travail y
est je savais vraiment une expérience
incroyable j'adore le journalisme en
région puis je pense aussi que c'est
important de valeur et journalisme en
région ne besoin de bons journalistes
pour faire des enquêtes en région mais
au moins donné j'avais envie moi de
faire de l'international
j'avais pas envie d'attendre d'avoir 40
50 50 ans puis qu'on me dise alors
sabrina c'est ton tour d'être la grande
correspondante de radio canada
parfois tu attends tu ta vie tu fais des
compromis puis finalement c'est jamais
ton tour tu étais un peu frustré aussi à
la fin de sa carrière
donc je me suis dit non moi je j'avais
un emploi permanent en plus donc mais je
suis parti j'ai laissé tout ça c'est pas
parce que je n'aimais pas ce que je fais
est ce parce que j'avais envie de voir
autre chose ça j'ai dû souvent dû
justifier parce que les gens
d'un emploi avec un fonds de pension ont
tendance à mais notre génération on est
moins attachée à ses acquis n'était pas
allé en tant que responsable pour le
canada non non non moi je suis partie en
fait pour faire l'histoire course partie
en afrique où j'ai bourlingué un petit
peu j'avais déjà étudié donc je partais
auto gauche parti dans l'est de la
république démocratique du congo j'ai
fait certaines expériences entre autres
avec oxfam où j'ai travaillé avec des
communautés vraiment le haut ou le bas
du journal et ce qui sera dit momon
objectifs en faisant société je m'étais
dit bon je vais pas sauter de l'autre
côté de la clôture parce que moi je suis
journaliste
fondamentalement mais je m'étais dit en
faisant de la communication sociale
c'est à dire le lien avec les
communautés avec certains programmes
c'est un programme de santé maternelle
et infantile est intéressant je peux me
rendre dans des endroits de l'ituri dans
l'est de la rdc où on peut pas se rendre
autrement je veux dire c'est vraiment
déçu vraiment très très loin il faut se
rendre par avion ça coûte cher
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses là je me
suis dit non moi c'est ça c'est vraiment
moi ces journalistes qui m'anime
après stuttgart à paris je trouvais
qu'on faisait pas assez internationale
au québec donc je m'étais dit je veux
ouvrir des portes dans les médias
français
j'ai fait ma maîtrise à sciences po
paris en journalisme international
et pendant ce temps là j'ai travaillé à
radio france internationale département
africain et international et au magazine
jeune afrique hausse et il ya eu les
attentats de paris en 2015 et donc là
j'ai travaillé pour des radios québec où
le secoue vrai les attentats de paris
les suit évidemment elle c'est là où
j'ai commencé à faire beaucoup plus de
piges et donc depuis 2000 15 mois
j'étais indépendante j'étais pigiste un
moment donné je me suis dit mon choix
mais moi on s'est dit bon c'est quoi la
prochaine étape après ma maîtrise qu'est
ce qu'on fait il m'avait suivi pas mal à
paris et ça ça lui avait coûté il y
avait fait des compromis donc sympa mon
tour de le suivre on a discuté puis j'ai
donc si tu as le contrat pour bureau de
jérusalem pour oxfam ce que lui
travaille pour le soir
seul bureau de jérusalem pour oxfam le
contreur au bureau
je te suis puis moi je vais me mettre à
fond pour que mes pige ça marche
donc ça a été vraiment difficile au
début parce que le métier de pigiste de
journalisme indépendant c'est vraiment
difficile mais je me suis donné à fond
puis ça a marché donc moi j'avais
plusieurs clients dont radio canada lors
du monde l'émission la 18h ou faisait
des reportages de 5-6 minutes sonorisé
ou parfois des directs ça dépend ça va
ça dépend des sujets donc j'ai toujours
gardé un lien évidemment avec
radio-canada jeu très radio canadienne
dans l'homme mais j'avais d'autres
clients parce que j'aurais pas pu vivre
à jérusalem au coût de la vie est super
élevé d'ailleurs
donc c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est
comment vivent à jérusalem comme le
cycle d'études et c'est ici au dessus
imagine sa dot est à la fois vraiment
beau mais à la fois tendu et on sait que
c'est comment est ce qu'il ya une
tension constante à skis car charest est
arrivé à jérusalem où j'ai vraiment pas
aimé ça
ça a été long avant que j'aime c'est
comme si parfois les premiers voyages
qu'on fait dans nos villes t on on tombe
en amour avec le pays puis tout est
extraordinaire j'en avais vu d'autres
puis je me suis fait l'objet me suis dit
c'est pas comme j'imagine est jeté et
j'étais un peu déçu puis après j'ai
comme appris à aimer le jérusalem a aimé
travailler en israël
aimer travailler dans un territoire
palestinien puis après le loge je suis
plus capable de décrocher je suis
vraiment attaché à cette région du monde
jérusalem
ça ressemble commenté jérusalem-ouest ça
ressemble un peu chez nous
bon évidemment que l'architecturé pas la
même mais si tu veux manger des sushis
pas de problème non mais c'est pas les
genres je sais pas ce que les gens
s'imaginent parfois il ya des gens qui
me disent ah ouais mais on s'imagine
colline avec quelques années une église
tout comme l'entente des décisions ces
mots des roues est tout à fait c'est
moins moderne que tel aviv par contre
c'est pas le même style du tout que tel
aviv sous une bulle et des gratte-ciel
tous à jérusalem il ya pas ça une
architecture spécial dans l'ouest des
pierres un peu beige un beige rosé le
typique des pierres de jérusalem cc6
très très beau et des quartiers qui sont
un petit peu moins beau parce qu'ils
sont un peu moins favorisés les
quartiers ultra-orthodoxes entre autres
dans l'est c'est complètement différent
lot un style plus palestiniens la rue
principale de salaheddine et des
commerces c'est pas le même style du
tout mais aussi la ville reçoit paul la
jérusalem s reçoit pas le même
financement de la ville donc c'est
sous-financé quand même dans sa part et
si tu - occidentalisée m oui tout à fait
c'est beaucoup plus moyen oriental je
dirais même si les palestiniens sont
prêts très ouvert et plein de femmes qui
portent pas le voile nécessairement des
signes chrétienne donc c'est assez
facile d'y vivre honnêtement c'est assez
facile la tension on la sent pas tout le
temps vraiment pas même il ya plein de
touristes dans la vieille ville de
jérusalem le même trop parfois je
rentrais d'abord je revenais de travail
et puis c'est comme on vivait dans la
vieille ville mais là c'est creux donc
là je devais marcher sur la loi district
law qui comme la rue principale du
quartier musulman
puis le racheter comme s'il vous plaît
excuse mais je devais essayer de passer
mais des groupes de touristes mais
c'était fatigant même temps que sa
paisible et commerçants de la vieille
ville donc je je t'écris moi pour mon
plein de chimie palestiniennes
israéliennes donc s biwetz communique le
librement ouais y'a pas de chèques
pointe entre les deux est la ville est
située dans jérusalem est par contre
puis quand je vous dis que tout un monde
qui l'est c'est parce que c'est vraiment
différent tu le sens quand tu passes
dans l'ouest mais c'est super prix alors
c'est à dire que moi en étant dans la
vieille-ville je sortais par la porte de
jaffa j'arrivais dans l'ouest
directement je peux aller prendre une
bière on allait prendre des bières avec
des amis ou à taklit là j'allais manger
des sushis aussi dans ce qu'on appelle
john maine colonies après le même soir
je pouvais aller dans l'est aller sur
une terrasse avec une vue sur la vieille
ville
je sais pas moi manger de n'importe quoi
oui oui vous tapez donc c'est sinon
c'est assez facile d'y vivre parce qu'on
sent pas les tensions
sauf que quand tu vis là assez longtemps
je sais très bien qu'il suffit d'une
étincelle pour que le visage de la ville
change complètement
c'est pas long là c'est vraiment comme
ça c'est un claquement de doigts puis on
m'en donnait là tout à coup ça change le
sait plus la petite ville touristique
l'ophone l'oasis de coexistence et plus
du tout lé je pense qu'il faut vivre le
puits bien connaître le contexte pour
reconnaître les agences web quand ça
arrive quand ça commence à monter la
tension aussi savoir c'est le temps dans
les choux est exactement quand c'est le
temps de s'éloigner un petit peu de la
foule quand c'est le temps de deux potes
m au mauvais endroit par rapport à la
police israélienne et des touristes qui
viennent y prendre des photos avec la
police israélienne c'est la dernière
chose à faire parce que parfois il ya
des attaques sur la police israélienne
depuis quand la police s'il ya quelqu'un
par exemple palestine et que s'avance
avec un couteau vers la police
israélienne ben évidemment que la pole
évidemment j'aimerais pas dire ça mais
la police khali9a répliqué avec des tirs
à balles réelles
si tu te reprend entre les deux une
bonne chance donc et c'est très tendue
dans ces moments là aussi parce que ça
arrive des tentatives d' attaque au
couteau d où des tentatives devrait dire
présumés d'attaqués au couteau parce que
parfois on n'est pas certain suis
vraiment tentative d' attaque au couteau
mais quand même c'est arrivé à plusieurs
reprises dans les dernières années
arrive tout
souvent ça me fait pas les manchettes
internationale tout près de chez moi où
je vais je vivais à lune
en près de l'esplanade des mosquées de
l'autre côté d'un petit check point
justement qui contrôlent l'entrée
l'esplanade des mosquées
donc chaque jour quand je sortais je
rentrais je devais passer par ce petit
check point claire et la police a fini
par le reconnaître mais ça a été
longtemps à chaque fois je devais me
justifier comme 8 juil jusque là oui
c'est pas évident c'est pas évident
parce que bon on a essayé de me parler
d'être sympathique de puymoyen chu dans
un contexte où c'est compliqué est ce
que tu es sympathique avec la police
israélienne qui est perçu comme
l'occupant par les palestiniens qui sont
tes voisins
j'ai pas nécessairement choisi de vivre
dans le quartier musulman côté
palestinien c'est qu'il y avait une
opportunité d'appartements là c'était
pas cher alors que le coût de la vie est
vraiment élevé donc j'allais vivre là
j'aurais pu très bien choisir mon
appartement dans l'ouest côté israélien
ma seule limite c'était pas dans les
colonies vda mal mais en même temps ça a
été l'un des plus bel endroit où j'ai
vécu dans ma vie prend l'apéro sur le
toit je veux dire les ciels sont doit
sauter le d'un côté tu vois le dôme du
rocher en or le soleil qui qui se
reflète sur le dôme du rocher les
pigeons qui volent auto à mosquée al
aqsa et entend l'appel à la prière
tu entends les cloches de saint sépulcre
les juifs qui prit au mur des
lamentations
non c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
c'est magnifique qui j'avais le spot
dans le choeur par hasard le tgs le spot
s'était pas c'était pas luxueux rien
c'est juste comme le bon ordre wars
vivre en appartement
typiquement de la vieille ville des murs
de pierre qui avait 700 en bourse est
toujours en train de défaire un peu j'ai
toujours une balayé métis étais et
c'était vraiment magnifique
ses autres pièces que c'est sécuritaire
mettant télé le soir tu te promener bara
la rose en vieille ville de tafer on est
revenu de 3 heures du matin parfois
puissantes aucune inquiétude
c'est un peu
le mauvais et le bon côté pardon de
l'occupation israélienne c'est à dire
que je suis mal à l'aise de dire sale
honnêtement mais c'est que il ya des
caméras partout [ __ ] la police armée
par tous n'est pas de vols
c'est les crimes en ayant tout à fait
tout à fait il y en a partout donc
qu'ils contrôlent
souvent de façon aléatoire les palestine
et qui circulent il voit par exemple un
shebab jeunes palestiniens qui a l'air
un peu bas qui trouve selon rue keller
loach ou encore qu'ils pensent qu'il
vient de la cisjordanie mais que pas de
permis pour né à jérusalem
ils vont le contrôle et ils n'ont pas
besoin d' excuses finalement pour pour
contrôler et surtout anguilles me les a
tous voila on peut dire que c'est une
forme de profilage racial les riley par
contre vous diront que c'est pour des
raisons de sécurité qui doivent faire ce
se soit l'argument qui revient en
bouclant la sécurité la sécurité la
sécurité le besoin d'israël de se
défendre face à ses ennemis
et quand on regarde l'histoire du
conflit on peut comprendre pourquoi en
48 49 sont attaqués par leurs voisins
arabes traumatisme qui sort de notre
enseignement exactement je me gêne qui
se joue dans ces dans leur narratif
c'est vraiment ça ça fait partie de leur
adn toujours avoir le sentiment qu'ils
doivent se défendre qui sont aujourd hui
à ceux qui sont persécutés
c'est pas faux d'une certaine façon
après 56 67 la guerre du yom kippour en
73 à une attaque surprise en pleine yom
kippour
ben quand on regarde les documentaires
sur l'histoire du conflit on comprend
pourquoi il sera aidé ce centre comme ce
type j'en ai côtoyé plein des israéliens
aussi qui explique ce traumatisme la
intergénérationnel qui nous disent ben
nous on est attaqué par nos voisins
depuis la création de l'état d'israël
on est attaqué par le hamas oubliez pas
que les israéliens sont quand même
passés à travers deux indicateurs
palestinienne donc en 89 et 93 puis en
2000 2005 et un soulèvement des
palestine et il y avait des attaques
très fréquente en
entre 89 93 87 pardon 93 c'est davantage
le soulèvement des pierres donc des
palestiniens caillassé des voitures avec
des pierres tout ça au début des années
2000 la seconde intifada elle et elle a
été très violente
c'était des attentats suicide dans les
bus à tel-aviv
ça a marqué sa vie sera signé on peut
comprendre le traumatisme qu'ils ont
donc quand on se promène dans le sud
d'israël qui ont une escalade avec le
hamas
ben euh nécessairement ils vont vous
dire qu'ils veulent nous tuer ils
veulent notre disparition ils veulent
notre destruction mais on comprend on
comprendre traumatisme qu'on comprend le
point de vue des deux le titiller peau
est pas une situation qui cliquaient
kebbell qu'il est doux tout le monde
sera là dedans puis tout le monde est
perdant
puis c'est quoi c'est comme un apport le
présentement telle à ce moment c'est les
affrontements métier à temps normal
c'est quoi la coexistence j'imagine
aussi que des palestiniens du côté ouest
jeu mais jean-louis pts qui n'est pas
tant que ça car qu'il était est ce que
est ce qu est ce qu est ce que ça sa vie
ensemble ce que ça à ce que dans les
bars à se mélanger dans les huiles
publié est ce que c'est une vanne qui
t'ont collègues au bureau et les
palestiniens pilotis tyrolienne ou c'est
quand même séparés au sein de la société
en israël il ya 20% de la population qui
est arabe israélienne donc palestine et
les arabes israéliens en israël ce sont
les descendants des palestiniens qui
sont restés sur le territoire israélien
après la guerre de 48 49 9 1% et donc
des villes mixtes en israël je pense à
nazareth
je pense à l'homme entre autres pistes
intéressantes se pose la question parce
qu'en ce moment
oui elles feront avec gasol mais ce qui
est très très inquiétant ce sont les
violences intercommunautaires qui se
déroule depuis le début de ce cas là
dedans les vélos
rires même de ces villes mix la guerre
des images de guerre civile qui nous
parviennent en tout cas jusqu ici où on
voit des affrontements entre des juifs
et des arabes israéliens les deux ont le
passeport israélien l'heure mais ils
s'affrontent par exemple on peut ne plus
voir un arabe israélien en palestine et
être lynché par un groupe de juifs
extrémistes en direct à la télé on a pu
voir des joueurs se faire battre en
direct à la télé il ya eu des barrages
filtrants ou on demande est ce que tu es
je foutais arabe
ça fait peur mais ça c'est ce qui
inquiète le plus en ce moment les
israéliens au delà de ce qui se passe à
gaza où chaque escalade à un peu des
commandes y suit des règles peut-être un
peu plus que ce genre d'affrontement le
et les affrontements intercommunautaires
se sont étendus comme une traînée de
poudre une douzaine de villes mixtes en
israël et donc la police il serait leur
envoyer des renforts de la police donc
là c'est un peu connu mais a eu des
synagogues incendié des gens qui ont été
blessés graves ont eu des morts
donc ça c'est vraiment un front qui
inquiète encore plus donc ils avaient
une certaine forme de coexistence
mais les arabes israéliens ou les
palestiniens vous diront d'israël
palestine israël vous diront quand même
qu'ils subissaient une discrimination
systémique quand même en étant des
citoyens de seconde classe
il y en ad'autres palestine et israël
qui s'identifie vraiment comme
israéliens d'autres qu'ils sentent
qu'ils s'identifient vraiment comme
palestine soyons pas toutes sortes et on
va avoir plus d'allégeance côtés
d'israël puis d'autres plus côté
palestinien mais je pense qu'ils sont
tous ils vont tous te dire qu'ils sont
palestiniens mais on a d'autres qui vont
se dire moi je joue l'identité c'est
fluide à lui donc il y en a qui vont
dire non moi j'aime pas quand tu
m'appelles arabes israël et moi j'suis
palestine ok rien d'autre que de choisir
tout et palestine est louche arabes
israéliens puisque je suis obligé de me
mettre dans une case
est-ce que je peux être à la fois arabes
israéliens palestiniens et chrétienne
par exemple ou et musulmane ça ça dépend
des personnes mais l'arabe israélien
vote aux élections ou un passeport
israélien
et ça c'est intéressant parce que ceux
de jérusalem est les palestiniens
jérusalem s n'ont pas de passeport en
majorité pas de passeport israélien us
qu'ils ont c'est une carte un permis de
résidence pour vivre à gérer
salam qui peuvent perdre à tout moment
il ya des inspecteurs et aussi sont pas
suffisamment là si par exemple ils ont
un chalet je sais pas moi j'irai copie
qui sont pas puis qui travaillent en
cisjordanie qui sont pas capables de
prouver que leur principal lieu de vie
c'est jérusalem
ils vont être expulsés vont perdre leur
père noël m donc ça c'est une autre
donc tu vois c'est vraiment comme une
autre classe de palestine et c'est notre
ils ont un statut complètement différent
en cisjordanie ils ont ils permis de
jérusalem ni de citoyenneté israélienne
ils ont une impasse pas un passeport une
carte de l'autorité palestinienne comme
c'est pas un pays c'est pas un passeport
officiel
plusieurs ont un passeport jordanien
parce que plusieurs sont considérés
comme des réfugiés de la guerre de 48 49
donc ils ont et pour les palestiniens de
cisjordanie ce par exemple ils veulent
venir prier à al aqsa bas ça leur prend
permis spécial ça c'est faut demander
aux israéliens ce qui qui qui ont le
pouvoir là dessus et bien sûr les
palestiniens de gaza
je vous en ai pas parlé beaucoup mais où
vivent ces deux millions de personnes
qui vivent sur une bande de terre de 40
km par à peu près une quinzaine de
kilomètres de large
coincé entre qu'israël l'egypte et la
mer méditerranée c'est l'ordre à la
pollution de plus denses au monde
l'ouest et donc une vive sous blocus
israélo égyptien
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire un
blocus ça veut dire que les mouvements
des personnes et des biens est
entièrement contrôlé par israël et par
l'egypte principalement par israël parce
que la principale spawn frontières mais
la principale frontières sont ouvertes
aux frontières internationalement
reconnues mais c'est israël donc et pour
aller vers les terres en palestine et
c'est beaucoup plus facile de passer par
israël
traverser le sinaï de prendre un avion
d'aller en jordanie puis d'autres
retraversant cisjordanie et donc et
vivent sous blocus depuis 2007 donc ça
fait quoi le 14 ans est depuis 2007
pourquoi vivent sous blocus israélien a
instauré un blocus sur la bande de gaza
après que le hamas ait gagné les
élections législatives dans la bande de
gaza en 2006 et comme les israéliens
sortait de la seconde intifada durant
laquelle amos avait commis pas mal
attaque les israéliens qui considère le
hamas comme un groupe terroriste a
imposé un blocus sur gaza et donc israël
contrôle tout ce qui rentre et qui sort
de la bande de gaza il ya eu trois
guerres lui trois guerres pour cette
nouvelle escalade meurtrière a eu 2008
2009 2012 et 2014 qui ont détruit des
pans entiers de gaza gazo qui vit une
situation humanitaire dans fait c'était
déjà invivable avant l'escaladé actuelle
et là les organisations internationales
se demande comment ça va se relever
j'entendais qu'ils y ont même il y avait
un chantre de puylaroque la cofidis est
encore pire lorsqu'il y avait un centre
de dépistage plus de vaccination puis ça
a été bombardée puis c'est détruire la
coved c'est vraiment relégué au second
plan des préoccupations des gazaouis en
ce moment alors que chez nous la
pandémie c'est comme une urgence cette
escalade cette escalade créer une
urgence sanitaire sur la bande de gaza
s'étaient déjà vraiment compliqué de
vivre à gaza
d'abord ils ont pas 24 heures
d'électricité pendant plusieurs années
ils ont eu seulement quatre 4 à 8 heures
d'électricité
qu'est ce que ça a comme conséquence
compte pas d'électricité ça veut dire
que les les pompes qui traitent l'eau
potable peuvent pas traiter l'eau
potable donc topo d'eau potable ça veut
dire que tu as du mal à faire des
activités quotidiennes des entreprises
ont du mal à faire rouler leur business
aussi faux que tu puisses avoir de
l'essence pour faire rouler des
génératrices pour les hôpitaux par
exemple j'avais pas mal de reportages là
tu dans le passé
par exemple l'unité de dialyse rénale de
l'hôpital al-chifa de gaza le plus grand
de l'enclavé a pas d'électricité
la majeure partie de la journée donc qui
il travaille avec des générateurs mais
quand il manque d'essence parce que
c'est aussi l'entrée des sens et contre
israël
qu'est ce que tu fais tes patients qui
sont en train de se faire dialyser le
donc filtrer le sang là faut que tu
pompes manuelles
c'est hyper stressant pour tous les
médecins qui travaillent le puits pour
les patients c'est des conditions de vie
qui sont extrêmement dures celui de
gazaouis sur 10 dépendent de l'aide
humanitaire
il ya plus de 50% des jeunes qui sont au
chômage
[Musique]
finalement nommé carrément sans blocus
simple crise les gens ne peuvent ni
entrer ni sortir
là c'est une escalade en ce moment là on
a envie de leur de bain juillet les
bombes fuir pour aller ou ne peuvent pas
sortir
ils ne peuvent pas sortir donc les
gazaouis se sentent pris dans une prison
ferme ont pris là là je sais que dans
les dernières heures
l'egypte a rouvert sa frontière avec le
sinaï pour laisser passer des blessés il
ya certains gazaouis qui sont plus
fortunés parce qu'il ya quand même des
gens corrompus le du côté des agents
l'égyptien là qu'il laisse passer
certaines personnes c'est vraiment
minime assez au congo donc on peut même
pas dire que c'est un phénomène
la majorité des gazaouis qui sont très
défavorisé reste à gaz en ce moment et
dans les bombardements eu aussi
plusieurs destructions de maisons donc
plusieurs personnes qui n'ont nulle part
où aller il ya des milliers de personnes
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
qui sont en ce moment dans les écoles de
l'unrwa l'agencé des nations unies pour
les réfugiés donc ils dorment dans des
écoles en espérant qu'au moins les
écoles donneront ne soit pas bombarder
c'est ce qu'on dit c'est extrêmement
difficile j'entendais
des lits et on fait dans l'entrevue avec
une jeune femme de 21 ans qui habite là
ce moment puis à l'expliquer sont
quotidiennes surtout maintenant
l'escaladé militaire puis à 10 on est
cloîtrée dans notre maison
puis on est on check sur notre fil
twitter quand qu'on peut voir si nos
amis sont encore sont encore la voir
qu'est-ce qui viennent se faire
bombarder puis à 10 quand on entend les
banques commençaient à tomber
si c'est ce que tu dis tantôt signe de
ses amis qui avait fait le tweak est
devenue virale de dire on se rejoint
tout donc dans le salon elle est avec
ses quatre frères et soeurs ses deux
parents dans une petite maison on se
rejoint tout dans le salon puis si on
est bon mais on va mourir ensemble et
puis si tu peux pas sortir de l'eau tu
peux rien faire
elle a dit que jo a check son son
cellulaire puis comme des places qui
sont chers à ses yeux la td librairie
d'entre eux mêmes qui se font bombarder
parce qu'arabes elle se savait de
disparaître puis de brûler le sait c'est
full of his extrêmement difficile parce
que les palestiniens ont l'impression
que il ya un aspect aléatoire aso est ce
que ce sont nous qui allons être
bombardé cette fois ci les israéliens
vous diront l'armée israélienne vous
dira qu ils bombardent principalement
des infrastructures du hamas des tunnels
où se cachent
des leaders du hamas on peut cacher des
armes aussi donc il bombarde au centre
de gaza city la ville de gaza qui à
l'intérieur de la bande de gaza bombarde
ce qui est ce qu'ils appellent le métro
c'est à dire un réseau de tunnels sous
le centre ville qui sert justement à
fabriquer des armes cachées des leaders
du hamas et israël dix bombardé sa
actuellement et qu'ils font tout pour
éviter de tuer des civils mais que le
hamas auxerre déçu mais les humains
évidemment que les palestiniens ont
réfuté les allégations des israéliens en
disant vous êtes capable de faire des
frappes chirurgicales quand c'est
nécessaire par exemple de détruire un
seul appartement d'un immense gratte
ciel comment vous ne pouvez vous savez
tout ce qui se passe au centimètre carré
dans la bande de gaza parce qu'ils ont
des drones de surnoms c'est tout comment
vous comment vous pouvez connaître le
fait comment vous pouvez bombardé un
endroit où il ya des femmes et des
enfants par exemple il ya eu ce que les
palestiniens ont appelé le massacre de
la rue hedda c'est une nuit où il ya eu
une quarantaine de morts dont plusieurs
femmes et plusieurs enfants en même
temps et israël à 10 parce qu'on a
bombardé des tunnels puis les
infrastructures se sont effondrés avec
des maisons finalement il ya eu beaucoup
de gens qui ont été pris sous les
décombres
voilà donc toujours deux versions qui
s'affrontent
il ya un peu de vrai je pense dans les
deux je vous dis pas que c'est égal je
vous dis pas que ces asymétries
contraire on peut pas compter le nombre
de bombes israéliennes qui tombe sur
gazon mais on peut compter le nombre de
roquettes du hamas
il serait là un dôme de fer des abris
anti roquettes ce que n'ont pas les
civils à gaza mais c'est probablement
vrai que le qu'israël bombarde les
infrastructures du hamas s qui peuvent
éviter des morts civiles est ce que
c'est une raison aussi pour pour tuer
selon le droit international des civils
est ce que parce que d'ici là on devrait
justement éviter de bombarder ses
infrastructures là je sais pas c'est des
questions qui se posent actuellement à
gaza puis les gars destinée c'est ça se
passe beaucoup ce qu'est ce qui fait que
c'est pas un crime de guerre met à
écrire me d'humanitaire maintenant un
crime de guerre
c'est ce que beaucoup d'eau et jazz en
ce moment qui disent que bien des deux
côtés on accuse l'autre camp de
commettre un crime un crime de guerre
finalement c'est la cour entre autres la
cour pénale internationale pour juger de
sa 'cela fait ça fait partie des lois
des lois qui dicte un petit peu ce qu'on
le droit de faire en temps de guerre ou
pas mais évidemment que de viser des
endroits où il ya des civils ou de
causer la destruction des maisons de
civils c'est pas permis
dans le droit international qui
encadrent un petit peu les conflits
armés qui notre bibi le sait quoi sont
on a parlé un peu de la politique du
côté palestinien
mais lui je pense qu'il est en poste
depuis 2009 je me trompe pas il ya une
autre forme ou s'ils s'accrochent
pouvoir le tpiy la faune est ce qui a
été élu démocratiquement élu nuit elia
ya un grand vide politique en ce moment
côté israélien vous parlais du vide
politique
côté palestinien un côté israélien en
quatre ans il ya eu quatre élections
dans les non pardon en deux ans il ya eu
quatre élections si je me mêle parce que
tellement de yano tellement eu qu'on
reparle compte dans l'est donc dans les
deux dernières années ou quatre scrutins
c'est un système proportionnel donc
c'est extrêmement difficile de former
une coalition pour gouverner
cette fois ci encore benyamin nétanyahou
a pas été en mesure de former une
coalition et donc le mandat a été donné
à naftali bennett qui est un de ses
adversaires et dar talib et ned pensée
ou entre analyser les dés de s'allier
avec des partis arabes pour gouverner
contre bibi et pour aussi signé la fin
du règne de m
qui est élu démocratiquement d'ailleurs
mais là avec ce qui se passe
actuellement avec l'escaladé militaire
avec les violences intercommunautaires à
l'intérieur d'israël
est ce que c'est possible de faire son
annonce est de moins en moins probable
alors naftali bennett au dip
je laisse faire je serais pas capable de
former un gouvernement donc j'abandonne
le mandat qui m'a été donnée par le
président israélien réouven rivlin
et donc probablement que ce qui va se
passer ce qui aura un autre scrutin dans
les 1 5e scrutin en 2000 dans les
prochains mois donc
benyamin netanyahou s qui a intérêt à
cette escalade militaire là entre que ça
lui donne des munitions par ce qui se
présente comme celui qui est capable de
gérer la situation
ça fait en sorte que ses adversaires
sont incapables de s'organiser
une fois son taux d'approbation de
popularité assez bon ouais tout à fait
le likoud et populaire il ay eu quand
même des grandes manifestations le dans
les derniers mois dernières années
compte benyamin nétanyahou parce que
aussi en procès pour fraude corruption
et abus de confiance et donc et donc son
sa cote de popularité ont un peu baissé
mais nous met dans un coin un conflit
comme ça si réussi à bien gérer les
choses à dire a donné une bonne raclée
au hamas sans que le bilan humain côté
israélien s'alourdissent trop il
pourrait sortir gagnante cette situation
le après si ça dégénère par exemple s'il
y avait une invasion terrestre de
l'armée israélienne à gaza qui est
beaucoup plus risqué qu'il y avait
beaucoup de morts côté israélien
peut-être que le son son étoile pâlir
est ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'il y avait
des changements de leaders mettant des
deux côtés ça pourrait être une avenue
va régler cette crise le où ça va
revenir au même finalement peu importe
peu importe qui tous pour un je pense
que c'est pas une question de leader je
pensais vraiment une question de fait
sur le terrain je pense qu'il faut
trouver des solutions à la situation
actuelle au 50 ans d'occupation au
blocus à gaza entre autres et peut-être
que si si c'était pas le hamas qui doit
pouvoir à gaza peut-être que les choses
seraient différentes
s'il y avait des élections le système
s'il y avait plus mahmoud abbas ça
serait peut-être le hamas qui serait
aussi en cisjordanie non qu'est-ce que
ce serait encore pire
peut-être si c'est pas biblique et au
pouvoir benyamin nétanyahou ça peut
aussi être quelqu'un qui est encore plus
à droite que lui
voilà bien encore pire ah ouais ouais tu
disais tantôt que tu avais vécu un match
qui a vu des bombardements à jérusalem
qui sait quoi qu'est-ce qui comme
comment cette vie ce qui se passe quand
ça arrive mais qui avait pas eu les
alarmes
mais les alarmes le jeune sam une couche
de plus l'ami comment est ce que tu vis
au quinté la macom journalistes on garde
un sang froid parce qu on est
professionnel et parfois dans la presse
internationale on a l'impression que
tout le territoire est à feu et à sang
mais c'est pas de la colle donc faut
quand même être clair comme vous je me
suis jamais sentie menacée en étant
jérusalem ou même en étant gaza ou
ailleurs en israël dans des villes
israéliennes que jamais senti que ta vie
est en danger dans ces situations là non
non mais est ce que c'est juste parce
qu'ils jouent un peu l'autruche parce
que techniquement il ya quand même un
aspect aléatoire au truc qui pourrait
faire que ce soit ravi bleus sans danger
que sur le plateau mont royal
non ça c'est ça c'est sûr ça c'est sûr
que probablement mon espérance de vie
diminuer quand j'étais à la molle mais
souvent on a l'image des journalistes
qui couvrent des zones de conflit un peu
comme des têtes brûlées qui vont prendre
des risques
bon moi ce n'est pas mon cas je libère
organisé je travaille de façon claire et
je prendrai pas de risques inutiles donc
la plupart du temps non j'ai pas craint
du tout pour ma vie c'est je suis
privilégié j'ai un passeport canadien et
ses rives quoi que ce soit - chaumont
passe pas en mode square dont je suis
canadienne de nous des coûts relève les
pieds bien perçue par sport canada
général oui c'est assez bien perçu
- pendant le ler stephen harper par
contre a ouais ça c'était plus compliqué
mais là c'est assez bien perçu de façon
générale juste un paradis père maciel et
puis c'est ça j'ai couvert de nombreux
escalade justement à gazon mais dans le
sud d'israël dans le sud d'israël en mai
2010 neuf lieux une pluie il y avait des
pluie de roquettes parce qu'israël
contrairement à avant le lance des
barrages de roquettes
le but c'est d'en lancer le plus
possible pour déjouer le dôme de fer que
quelques roquettes qui puisse passer à
travers les mailles du filet puis causé
des dommages et j'étais à ashkelon quand
il ya eu au moins donné des centaines de
roquettes
et oui c'est stressant parce que je me
suis jetée dans une sur le terrain d'une
maison où la veille où durant la nuit
avait une roquette qui avait tué un
homme
j'allais rencontrer la famille pour
faire des entrevues bon j'allais voir
comment ça se passait le trou dans la
cour et b1 un gros 1 vraiment gros trou
l'homme était sur sa terrasse est en
train de fumer une cigarette puis se
disait probablement complexe règne un
bon voilà la roquette vaut pas terrible
sera pas ici
cette atterri dans son jardin et puis il
ya eu des éclats d'obus puis le
il est décédé donc il est mort à trois
reprises en l'espace de quelques minutes
j'ai dû courir moi même aux abris dans
cette maison là où l'homme a été tué
dans l'abri anti roquettes de cette
famille qu'il y avait une âme brillante
sur requête longueuil c'est sortir son
abri pour fumer du pot et cigarettes
vont vous de suite ça jamais été
confirmée par la police cette version là
mais non officiellement c'est ce qui
s'est passé à un moment donné aussi
quand il ya des halles rda lampe toute
la nuit
j'imagine que aussi comment normaliser
la situation puis bon bon je vais pas là
la vraie cette fois ci parce qu'il est
mon mais là c'est arrivé que cette fois
là elle est au mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment et c'est vrai que de
courir aux abris
c'est stressant olivier je veux dire je
peux en témoigner j'ai vu aussi le la
peur dans les yeux des gens qui venaient
de perdre un proche donc la famille où
c'est un abri anti roquette le sens un
peu comme une garde-robe c'est tout
petit point les gens entrepose je sais
pas moi leur boisson gazeuse
quand est ce un peu comme un garde
manger finalement c'est ici mais s'est
renforcée et on était tous coincés comme
ça dans l'abri anti roquettes on attend
pendant tant d les bombes dont ça veut
dire qu'il ya des gros coup qui tombe à
des endroits et après on a pris la route
et quand il ya une alarme on est sur la
route faut arrêter sortir et se mettre
par terre coucher au sol les mains sur
la tête donc ça aussi c'est arrivé
pourquoi parce que c'est une roquette
souvent par pascal de chaussée une
roquette qui tombent près les éclairs de
bus vont voler dans les airs dont faut
être au sol mais aussi parce que des
missiles guidés ou six qui visent
parfois des véhicules donc le nous on
était très près de là de la clôture avec
gaza donc ça aurait été possible que le
véhicule dans lequel on était soit visée
par un missile guidé donc là dès qu'une
alarme
on sort de la voiture puis on se met
plus loin au sol donc je l' ai vécu puis
c'est vrai que j'ai pas eu peur pour ma
vie durant ces moments là mais j'ai pu
comprendre par convient quiétude des
israéliens c'est vraiment dans ces
moments là où ça aide comme journaliste
à comprendre mieux comprendre le
narratif d'israël après à gaza c'est là
peut-être où j'ai peut-être eu peur pour
ma vie à un moment donné ou
il y avait la marche du retour je sais
pas si ça vous dit quelque chose c'est
ok quand trump a dit que jérusalem est
est la capitale d'israël
ça a soulevé un tollé dans les
territoires palestiniens à gaza ils ont
choisi de manifester contre cette
décision là pour réclamer jérusalem et
réclamer leur droit au retour des
réfugiés et donc par milliers les
gazaouis sont alimani festi le long de
la clôture avec israël et il menace est
ce que c'est littéralement une clôture
ouais il ya des certains booth et des
murs en béton bien d'autres bouts c'est
vraiment juste des barbelés et donc il
est l heure puis se sont rendus jusqu'à
la clôture est il menacé ils arrivent
avec des grosses pinces puis menacé
d'ouvrir pour retourner chez eux ce que
ce qui ce que considère comme chez eux
et donc évidemment qu'israël a eu peur
d'une de d'avoir des infiltrations je le
mets entre guillemets sur son territoire
donc ils ont déployé des snipers
israéliens tout le long de la clôture
vraiment le long des 40 km de la bande
de gaza puis c'était des milliers de
gazaouis qu'ils allaient manifester
aussi contre le blocus temps c'est une
manifestation très englober toutes leurs
revendications lui beaucoup de morts par
balles et surtout beaucoup de blessés
parce que les snipers visait les
palestiniens principalement dans les
genoux
et donc eu énormément de blessés graves
des gens qui sont handicapés aujourd'hui
et je me trouvais dans la zone tampon de
300 m donc ça entre le sniper depuis la
grille de maintenant entre la grille de
métal et la partie plus sécuritaire qui
en feront vous avez israël d'un côté il
ya une clôture perd ensuite c'est gaza
si tu entres dans les 300 mètres de la
zone tampon l'étudiant est un peu une
menace pour israël
donc tu peux être la cible d'un tir et
donc moi je faisais des entrevues ça en
début de journée ce vendredi où il y
avait encore des manifestations et et là
on s'approche et je fais une entrevue
avec un vendeur de crème glacée c'est un
petit monsieur qu'une famille qui vend
de la crème glacée pour trois fois rien
et donc moi je suis pour la radio et je
mets une entrevue que j'ai mon fixeur
avec moi et là on entend que la clac
clac clac ce cd on s'imagine qu'un bruit
de deux d'armes ça fait beaucoup plus de
bruit au nom des petits claquement tout
petit peu ça voulait dire qui tirait etc
et là j'ai comme je dois me ressemble
qu'est-ce qu'on fait parce que j'entends
des claques et des bas je trouvais que
c'était bon il y avait un journaliste
qui avait été tué dans les semaines
précédentes avec une veste pare-balles
écrit presse dessus donc les simples
israël etc sont pas si loin que ça moi
je les voyais jeudi à ses jambes sont
pas loin ils ont aussi dans l'eure avec
leurs fusils j'imagine une espèce de
vision je visais exactement donc pour
voir où ils visent ils savent ni 6
passes et pau wazari vis pas au hasard
et donc est donc là je joue j'ai eu un
petit frisson le bon je pense que je
vais reculer quand même je voulais
absolument aller sur le terrain pour
voir qui se trouve dans la zone tampon
parce que israël disait que c'était
principalement des combattants du hamas
qui allait leur c'est comme ça qu'il
justifiait la répression très forte de
ces rassemblements le ci avait pas de
journalistes dans la zone tampon pour
aller voir est ce que c'est vraiment des
militants du hamas mais given le crime
la cible ouais exactement et il ya aussi
avait aussi des grands mères
palestiniennes y avait des enfants
habits presque avec un habit du dimanche
mais c'est le vendredi c'est leur jour
de prière y avait des femmes y avait des
jeunes
il y avait aussi des jeunes qui
revenaient puis l'autre sur les voiliers
avec le foulard palestinien qui allait
lancer des pierres
il y en avait évidemment
tout d' absurde dans cette robe c'est
comme si c'est une réalité est là c'est
parfois des cocktails molotov aussi ya
eu à certains moments pour ça la marche
du retour ça a duré des mois des mois
des mois des mois nous a donné ça s'est
un peu affaibli la mobilisation que ça
s'est arrêté mais ça a duré longtemps
souvent après le vendredi la marche de
retour y avait une escalade militaire où
l'on parce qu'ils avaient des morts côté
palestinien le hamas lançaient des
roquettes qu'israël répliquent avec des
bombardements
ça se terminer comme ça il n'y avait pas
ça on n'allait jamais vers une guerre
totale mais les escalades était de plus
en plus forte je dirais donc là où je me
suis dit ouais ça c'était mais en même
temps je trouvais que c'était important
d'aller voir qui était un scénario un
tampon là donc j'ai seulement reculé
puis ça allait on a reçu une pluie de
gaz lacrymogène par contre il a fallu
quand même quitté rapidement ce qui
viennent avec des drones au dessus nos
tailles pour larguer des gaz
lacrymogènes
cette fois la plupart pour ma vie mais
je me suis dit bon on prendra pas de
risques qu'un convient qu'un convoi
mettons ces scènes le pis c'est cette
réalité-là de ces gens le piquet titan a
entendu les balles siffler autour de ce
que c'est quelque chose qui change de
l'intérieur de ce cas précis en
perspective sur la vie en général
belle philosophie comme question mais
c'est très philosophique car j'ai vu
beaucoup de blessés graves soit dans les
centres d mais c'est faux si puis après
je me disais c'est vrai que je me disais
mais petit bobo là on va arrêter d'avoir
ces deux parfois j'avais envie de me
plaindre sur certaines choses qui est
insignifiante je me dis bon je vais me
calmer
ce cm mais en même temps je sais pas
comment expliquer mais comme journaliste
évidemment que je suis touché par ce qui
se passe parce que je vois autant côté
palestinien qu'israélien ça c'est sûr
puis moi ma méthode de travail c'est que
je me laisse imprégner par ce que je
vois parce que je vis je laisse les
émotions monter ça m'est déjà arrivé
dans une entrevue quand j'étais au
kurdistan irakien où j'ai pleuré parce
que j'étais trop touchés par ce que
j'entendais un père qui avait perdu ses
deux filles aux mains de l'état
islamique de répéter cela mais qu'il est
les cherchons encore aujourd'hui un qui
avaient été otages fait esclave sexuelle
bref j'ai été plus je me laisse
imprégner par ça mais après quand je
reviens soit dans ma chambre d'hôtel ou
chez moi pour écrire mon reportage où le
monte c'est pour la radio lors je prends
la distance professionnelle nécessaire
mais sinon c'était pas une certaine
empathie
comment tu peux bien rapporter ce que
vivent les gens sur le terrain puis moi
je pense que c'est ce que plus
intéressant en journalisme c'est d'aller
à la rencontre des gens de la rue je
veux dire la diplomatie l'histoire les
couches géopolitique la théologie ce
conflit là et qu'on peut être peut
paraître complexe mais qu'on va parler
aux gens dans la rue il ya vraiment rien
compliqué j'imagine que tu sais
je extrapolé mais quand tu vois ce plus
difficile après ceux de j'imagine d'être
d'accepter quand des gens ici disent que
les mesures pour contrôler la population
et les mesures sanitaires mettons le cas
sourire c'est ça ces gens là ouais tu
penses qu'un gouvernement qui veut
contrôler la population c'est ce qui
nous laisse aller d'un parc parce qu'on
veut lui ça remet en perspective soit
aussi mais ça me fait sourire mais je
passe mon tour j'imagine aussi que théo
en début des podcasts et ses défauts la
perception ici on comprend pas justement
la la la complexité de ces conflits le
puits où sont notées de pas l'avoir vu
de pas l'avoir vécue deux pôles pour un
contact avec sérénité le style d'abord
je te demande
l'empathie nécessaire pour comprendre un
peu la réalité des honnêtes citoyens des
deux côtés de l'image il cite deux fois
qu'en attendant ici la perception de
certaines personnes qui comparaissent a
fallu des dreads aussi aussi depuis
quelques jours je te dirais que nous
aurait sinon j'ai entendu des choses
c'est moi je trouve pas plus acceptable
et commentaires antisémites contre les
israéliens contre les juifs par ce à
cause de ce qui se passe à gaza c'est
pas plus acceptable et l'inversé est
vrai aussi les commentaires que ce soit
islamophobes ou anti palestiniens rien
de ce que moi je trouve acceptable
de toute façon dans tous les conflits
moi je prends le parti des civils je
dois importe peu importe la situation
moi c'est ce qui m'intéresse le plus
c'est les conditions de vie de ces gens
là
est ce que le droit est respecté le
droit humanitaire le droit international
c'est souvent ma ligne les droits
humains et les droits de la personne est
ce que c'est ça c'est respecter
j'accepte pas non effectivement dans des
remarques comme ça je vais réagir mais
j'ai aussi beaucoup entendu c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai accepté de
devenir jase avec vous dans ce podcast
mais j'ai entendu aussi de beaucoup de
faussetés se sont dites sur sur le
conflit israélo palestinien
j'ai quelques idées mais je comprends
que ça peut être compliqué mais faut
donner le temps nécessaire pour la
compréhension de ce qui se passe parce
que sinon on ne joue pas notre rôle
comme journaliste et comme média je
comprends que dans les médias
traditionnels c'est plus compliqué on
n'a pas beaucoup de temps mais justement
la minute trente que toi pour le faire
choisi les bons mots importants c'est
pour ça aussi que j'aime et ce à tout le
monde en parle a new day à la fin duquel
a dit d'arrêter de le dire les juifs si
ou lé palestine et sud est il de faire
des grandes généralités ccpo le peuple
n'est pas la décision de son étau et
tant pis si c'est pas un bloc
monolithique le terrien qui rit qui si
simple la société israélienne est très
très diversifiée on peut pas dire les
israéliens comme si c'était un bloc
monolithique juste d'amener les
palestiniens
il ya plusieurs identités dans chacun
des camps processus est vraiment
complexe en même temps parfois il ya
quand même faut dire les choses aussi
cogné un groupe de juifs extrémistes qui
lynchent un palestinien en pleine rue
une basse et un groupe c'est ce groupe
de jeu fait foi et précis dans ce qu'on
souhaite presse précise qu effectivement
dans ce qu'on dit ouais merci beaucoup
ça fait plaisir merci à vous c'était
vraiment super conversation je pense que
ça va en éclairer plusieurs heures dont
moi moi moi c'est au-dessus des projets
qui sont à rien de travailler sur quoi
présentement balog suis à bala j'avoue
que je suis ce qui se passe là bas et je
meurs dans envie de m'acheter un billet
d'avion bateau tu vois ça te faire ou à
lons
oui parce que je me dis ils ont besoin
des journalistes qui comprennent le
contexte râler couvrir ses débuts des
amis qui sont encore la bosse des
territoires que je connais bien ce que
tu mets ton que pas de cessez le feu tu
es le cas mais si j'étais à actuellement
jerusalem - le check point pour entrer
fermé mais dès qu'il ouvrirait jld c'est
sûr et certain que j'irais là comme
indépendante mon problème ça c'est une
autre réalité journalisme indépendant
c'est que ça coûte extrêmement cher se
rendre là-bas faut payer pour un fixeur
aussi sur place à gaz on ne peut choix
c'est une résidante de le mentionner les
fixeurs fixeur c'est quelqu'un de la
boxe journaliste local qui va mettre son
nom sur le permis du hamas qui
responsable de toi donc si tu dis une
connerie lui peut vivre les conséquences
de ce dossier la masse est pas non plus
un enfant de choeur c'est pour un groupe
s'implique pas vip à 100% librement non
plus dans la bande de gaza on n'en a pas
beaucoup parlé mais messi mais c'est le
cas aussi donc la mort ce contrôle quand
même qui entrent sur son territoire donc
c'est ce que j'aurais envie mais c'est
un peu compliqué pour l'instant donc là
je suis ce qui se passe mais je
travaille comme temporaire à
radio-canada donc je vais je fais de la
rédaction de la présentation des
bulletins nouvelle je travaille non je
participe à des balades au marché
pendant d'affaires j'ai des projets
personnels à côté mais pour l'instant je
je vous dirais que ce que je fais c'est
que la nuit quand je suis ce qui se
passe à gaza que monfils se réveille
dans la chambre à côté puis que j'essaie
de l'entraîneur qui sera donc tout seul
je veux dire qu'il vient dormir dans le
lit avec maman parce que je vois ce que
les mères vivent à gaza et en israël
je trouve ça extrêmement difficile
d'être témoin de leur réalité sans
pouvoir faire quoi que ce soit je me
sens très impuissante fait que j'essaie
de me rendre compte de mes privilèges
merci beaucoup je vous en prie un simple
merci d'avoir écouté ce podcast jusqu'à
la fin de ce pas que vous avez apprécié
la conversation ça prouve que vous êtes
de réelles fans de conversation et sans
fil pas de casser on vous remercie
vraiment
coup si vous voulez avoir plus de
contenus plus de conversations sur
pétillante que ça se passe hier sur ps3
non seulement on met tous les podcasts
en ligne au moment où est ce qu on les
tourne donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pétrole mais on fait
aussi des encore moins de filtres qui
sont exclusifs au monde pétulant nous
aussi quand on parle d'homme nicole et
moi de la conversation convient d'abord
parce qu'on met un peu plus en
profondeur dans certains sujets qu'on
voulait aborder ou qu'on a abordé
pendant le podcast donc allez sur notre
page rituels les le lien vers savoir
dans la description du podcast qui a
merci encore une fois nous avons écouté
jusqu'à la fin